foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challengers ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best from Carlson's fiercest online
rival today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps lodibeck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh dollar Raju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and Shakira
mamagyarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
hello and welcome to the moment we have
all been waiting for the grand finale of
Norway chess on this final day of Chess
of and Armageddon who will emerge
Victorious will it be tournament leader
Fabiana caruana or will it be Hikaru
Nakamura that will snatch Glory at that
last minute stay tuned because today it
is all happening I'm your host
International Marcia vancouzka and as
always it's a great pleasure to be here
in the Stavanger Studio alongside the
legendary Grandmaster Judy poga and the
awesome Grandmaster and commentator
David Howell oh we are coming to the
final moment it's what the world has
been waiting for and Judith there are
two contenders Fabiana caruana and
Hikaru Nakamura Hikari isn't a must-win
situation he needs to win the classical
game how can he do it
well that's a good question he has to be
very brave and he has to have a very
straightforward forward mindset for it
and of course a very good opening
preparation
and luck okay
and David of course on the other end of
the board is Fabiana carwana who has
been playing Amazing chess so far but
what does he have to do to make that
much needed draw for Fabiano it's just
about doing what he's done throughout
the entire tournament he's been by far
the most impressive player up to this
point he's looked untroubled other than
just one game and if he's solid if he
doesn't allow the nerves to get to him
he still starts as the favorite okay and
it was a very exciting day yesterday at
Norway chess for tournament leader
Fabiano caruana it felt like business as
usual as he comfortably secured a draw
against Wesley so with the white pieces
and then outwitted Wesley in the
Armageddon but there was one person
gukash who actually won their classical
game in very stylish fashion is good
cash having the tournament of his
lifetime Judith I think he's having a
great tournament he won two classical
games and he's fighting like a lion
and David yesterday four armageddon's
some surprising results there yeah yeah
surprising results including importantly
for the standings abdicator of beating
Nakamura in the Armageddon and uh yeah
it's been up and down for a lot of
players but Magnus Carlson now on seven
out of seven Armageddon wins in a row
will he add another one to his
collection today I can't wait to find
out we'll see what his strategy is and
let's take a look at today's well the
rounds standings and at the top of the
table it is fabulous Fabiano caruana
with an amazing 16 points out of 24 in
second place Hikaru Nakamura 13 and a
half but take a look at all those people
in contention for second place yukash
and his Curie and Wesley so all have a
shot at securing a lot of money so a lot
of action today and uh talking about
what is happening today well there is
only one match and that is the big
encounter between Hikaru Nakamura with
the white pieces he in second place
against Fabiano caruana this one is
gonna be red hot
any other matches that's kind of stand
out for you well obviously everybody is
going to be watching that specific game
between the two Americans but I'm also
very much interested about what's going
on how vesely will be playing against go
cash because still last round still
something to fight on and I like to see
gokash how is he going to do is he going
to get past spawns again yeah and David
what a youth what have you got your eyes
on oh it's the big American Clash there
but also Magnus Carlson Will he win a
classical game this will be the first
time in years and years that he will not
have won a classical game in a
tournament if he fails to beat Abdul
sotorov today so for him ending in the
tournament on a high I think will be all
important certainly and there's a lot of
Chess at norwichs and Everyone likes the
stats so we've collected them for you
basically we have collected the amount
of openings that have been played and
there you can see at the top is the rui
Lopez and you can see it hasn't had a
successful outing only 43 in White's
favor are there any other stats that
stand up for you Judith there for me
something is wrong there because I see
that this is still a zero Victory with
white and four droves and one losses
there's something really wrong here if I
would have been playing on the
tournament for sure that will be a
little bit different so this is
a challenge for you Judith and for you
David what surprises what strikes out uh
what stands out to me is the fact that
the Roy Lopez the Sicilian Judith and
the Italian are three of White's most
popular openings after one E4 there have
been no wins for white there in the
classical encounters that means E4
struggling this tournament in the longer
games really fascinating stats and there
is an honorable mention to the London
system because some good cash played it
yesterday just the ones and he got 100
record I'm getting bragging right says
The Londoner and of course Norway chess
you know it is a fighting chess
tournament and it's all due to the
unique tournament format and take a look
at this you know it's a 10 player single
round robin
120 minutes for the entire game there is
no increment added until the players
reach move 40 and pawn which 10 seconds
is added per move it's not a lot of time
and in the case of a draw it is
Armageddon that breaks the tie so much
fun so much chess and of course no draw
offers before move 30.
and here we are it is the encounter that
has been building now for days Hikaru
Nakamura against Fabiano caruana the
podcaster versus the streamer
or two super Grand Masters actually yeah
and interestingly until the last second
there was no eye contact at all just uh
dodging any kind of any eye contact
there Hikaru but occasionally looking
over at his opponent you can feel the
tension in the uh Hikaru determined to
win this one it is a win or nothing for
him second place he won't be happy with
and for Fabiano a draw will guarantee
the title but of course with the black
pieces no guarantees
well absolutely you can feel the tension
don't you the way Nakamura is sitting
right there and then time to time he
looks back with his eye not turning his
head just looks a little bit on Bobby
there's no friendliness there at all
and the Hikaru did actually stay in an
interview yesterday that these two were
not Rivals there was no animosity
between them but they were competitors
and here is another important encounter
and this one could potentially determine
second place if everything backfires
with Hikaru where's he say with the
white pieces against younger cash now 17
years old who really is performing
absolutely marvelously
might be only 17 but on the live
rankings right now he's number 13 in the
world he could get very close to the top
10 if he wins this game against Wesley
uh really really impressive stuff from
the teenager
yeah on the edge of 17 and Magnus he's
got to uphold Norwegian honor here in
front of the home fans neither of the
Norwegian players has won a classical
game so far in the event so he will want
to change that put the record straight
but not about great day yesterday taking
down Hikaru in the Armageddon it
wouldn't be an easy battle I think it
was an easy victory for him so now today
is still all his energy can put into the
last round yeah
and to the interesting psychological
scenario for Hikaru here because if
Hikaru takes too many risks and it all
backfires on him
he there are other people waiting
in the lines to kind of catch him up you
know you have good cash half a point
behind him also Wesley siren and Niche
Geary they're on 11 and a half points
with classical wins in their encounters
they can LeapFrog over Hikaru so my
question is
like how much risk should Hikaru take
well I know that we want him to take
risks the fans want him to take risk his
viewers on his channel want him to take
risks because first prize
eternal glory going down in the history
books that's the most important thing
but as you mentioned Ivanka tumbling
down to fourth or fifth place would not
be a great way to end the tournament so
yeah it's hard to say drew that you've
been in situations like this before what
do you think hikara's approach should be
well I think it's very difficult to say
because uh
Hikaru had to make a decision how he
wants to play I think he can only win if
he has a very clear strategy not only
generally talking about the opening
preparation but also if he decided in
his mindset that he's going to give all
in he's not going to be ready for
compromises and he even ever it's
possible he's going to go for a risky
play or
maybe he's not going to play risky at
all and so far in this opening as we've
seen it was not so successful so far in
this torment so after we can't say that
E4 is a mistake these days but according
to the stats we could yeah absolutely
and uh Knight F3 we predict that Fabi
will also develop his 1996 and now
Hikaru looking up to the ceiling is he
gonna develop his Bishop to B5 Bishop C4
it's an Italian it's an Italian good
news for Hikaru is that it will lead to
a very tense game he has a lot of
experience here mostly from the black
side the bad news is that not nobody has
won with white in the Italian in the
classical this tournament either and wow
going for in the two nights variation
he's going for the fried liver attack
he's hitting the F7 Pawn uh this is uh
at least it was popular my youth Ivanka
Judith is this a surprise to you not
many top players employ this Knight G5
move these days I was actually
recommended by Wesley so in his
chessable course and I tried my hand at
it a few times online and I got it was
it was too much Greed for lack of
development okay we see porn takes porn
and you won't hear me say often say
those words sometimes it's good to
suffer extra material
well is uh Nakamura going to be testing
for this memory or does he have
something
special
repaired Cooks cooked for today
and this position does lead to a pawn
sacrifice this move confirms it Fabiano
wasn't able to recapture a porn in the
center earlier there were some really
nice tactics really nice tricks there
for white instead he's gaining time
against the white Bishop white is a pawn
up but we'll have to lose a lot of Tempe
now retreating white select Square
Bishop retreating White's knight from G5
over the next couple of turns in Bishop
D3 this move was trendy a few years back
but there's a lot of theory here Fabiano
of course will have done his homework
you don't sacrifice the pawn when you're
happy with the draw unless you're 100
sure of what's Happening uh what do you
make of this Judith what's transpired on
the board
actually I have no idea what's going on
here because I was playing it with none
of the colors and the
I think it's all worked out it's
vertical
yeah there are several sensible Sensible
moves Knight D5 interesting attacking
the Knight on G5 and having ideas of
Knight F4 attacking yeah G2 D3
Bishop
this is one of the main lines still uh
here black usually plays the move Bishop
to D6 just to defend the uh E Pawn but
there are sharper Alternatives as well
D6 I'm expecting and yeah there's a
couple of sharp lines here either after
uh White Castle's black goes for Knight
F4 it becomes very positional after
capturing the bishop on D3 or black
often even just strikes out as quickly
as possible by playing the move F5 and
there's been a lot of developments there
they've been games between uh Wesley
Stone Magnus Carlson they've been plenty
of lines where black sacrifices even
more material
but right now I'm pulling down Fabi
needs a quick development to compensate
and uh he does develop his dark squared
Bishop
and uh Fabi I have to say is the picture
of Serenity at the chessboard whereas
Hikaru you feel that he's kind of
begging himself for that moment
choosing a compromising Bono a very
principled opening
and uh well hikara castle in the king
yeah gearing himself up for battle that
white King's safe now and it's up to
Fabi to create some play in what we call
the fried liver attack black upon down
can I ask why it's called the fried
liver attack no idea okay
I was just wondering on that that well
it sounds like I'm a kitchen in the
kitchen I understand those things but
here
sounds like something out of Silence of
the Lambs but meanwhile okay black snake
has landed on F4 we're expecting this
bishop to be captured next move wrecking
the white Pawn structure so the
composition will be strategic this is
shaped up though for a nice fighting
game I'm really happy we saw this
opening rather than the Berlin or
something a bit duller Yeah completely
agree with you there David and actually
will Fabiano be feeling stressed in this
particular game in this particular
position well we asked him prior to this
game when our reporter svara caught up
with him let's have a listen to what he
had to say
I don't think we could have scripted A
better ending right now it's all on the
line you have to maintain a draw with
black pieces how do you view the game
say
yeah I feel good about the situation but
it will be very tough I'm sure and
um it's one of those classic scenarios
you know we both have it all online now
just the kind of situations and the kind
of last rounds that you dream about as a
chess player in the kind of tournament
the way a tournament should be ended
well it's uh let's say the stress isn't
ideal but it's for the for the
spectators it's very good
do you feel that kind of stress when
you're sitting at the actual game
uh more before once the game starts it
usually feels like
like you you worry about the stuff that
could happen before the game and then
once you're in it then you you kind of
get in the mode of more playing and less
worrying we look forward to that mode
and good luck thank you
more playing and less worrying it's
interesting that Fabiana does did
confess that he suffers a little bit
from the pre-game nerves
but I think that's how it should be if
he wouldn't then that that would be bad
okay so you need that nervousness just
to add that adrenaline to the system I
think you you do have to have it really
to to sense it and to be sensitive to
small details in the game
and a few David do you ever get nervous
and
before games in general and then I'm
going to add in this particular
situation where there is a lot at stake
let's just say I'm glad it's them I'm
not me playing right now I'm glad
they're dealing with the pregame Jitters
um yeah I always found it extremely
tough especially last round so I had a
terrible score in last rounds because I
was too focused on the result the rating
the prize money and stuff like that and
of course these players need to put that
to the back of their mind but easier
said than done like you said it's often
good if you're slightly nervous not too
nervous just because it means you're in
the zone you're carrying you're kind of
sharp and alert but uh yeah I'm sure
these guys they've been there before
plenty of times themselves so they know
how to handle these situations from
experience
and uh yeah I like in the future chat
there Hikaru professional incoming home
waiting with anticipation here excited
for that moment too
I like the choice what the Hikaru did I
think it's uh it's something we have to
appreciate that he really came out he
wants to test Fabi and he wants to
challenge it with okay
I know that your your development your
compensation is good but still I have a
pawn up so show me that you can save
yourself
show me the money and actually according
to my chess.com database this has only
been played six times before but two of
those games were by Lavon aronian one
last year against uh Hans Neiman and uh
in another one in 2019 against dingleran
and I have to say in both those games
Lavon aronian Drew
well it's very much of uh Iranian style
he very much likes this kind of
positions taking initiative compensation
active display working it out very
deeply for very long which is probably
the case in fabi's case as well but
simply the spirit of the position is
very much for aranyana I believe
yeah great compensation here for black
if you just look at the Statics the kind
of outline of the position you see these
doubled pawns for white and they are big
big targets Fabby deciding maybe how to
go for these you can go for these pawns
with your Bishop for example you don't
necessarily need to rush either uh maybe
from A6 from F5 as well another typical
Motif in these positions is to push your
Pawn to C5 to bring back this stranded
knight from A5 just re-centralize it
bring it back to the C6 square and from
there you have great control over the
center you just play as if you're not a
pawn down and just hope that White's
structural defects will later hold him
back from gain gaining an advantage
often as well the light Squad Bishop
because it is unchallenged Lands
perfectly on the long diagonal similar
to The Marshall similar to other
openings as black where you sacrifice
upon for activity early in the game
but Fabiano thinking he's paused for a
while now it must have been a long time
since he's looked at this opening uh it
doesn't happen every day this variation
good psychological Choice from hankaru
absolutely I like it very much and okay
in the interview we could feel that Fabi
was nervous because probably just the
idea I mean it's probably if he would be
losing this game it would be one of the
most painful losses in his career
right yeah always last round losses it's
not only that I mean he really played
very well he won four classical games he
played very good very interesting games
he won brilliancy game versus alireza
and he was still all the way in the lead
and usually by the way this can be
dangerous because there are very few
tournaments where you see someone take
the lead and it goes all the way until
the very end yeah I was also gonna ask
you about the impact of the media on a
say Fabi and Hikaru because you know the
questions that they must be facing all
the time are you nervous are you
stressed how are you gonna sleep tonight
those kind of questions you know which
perhaps if the media wasn't there or you
know your social network isn't there
they're not going to be putting these
thoughts into your head
basically it's not the media who puts it
in their head they have it by itself
and I don't think they they are bothered
with these questions because it's such a
general question that are you nervous
how do you think the outcome what
opening it's gonna be are you stressful
etc etc that they are
uh they're just ignoring it basically
okay
so you mentioned at Ivanka these guys
one is a streamer one is a podcaster
it's not as if they uh kind of shunned
the media they welcome it they uh kind
of they're very self-aware they for know
these questions are coming they know
what kind of people are going to be
talking about and they found ways to
embrace that and to kind of work it in
their own favor to motivate themselves
and I think this is one of the things
which is very different the Chess World
we're having right now compared to the
times when I was uh let's say 15 20
years ago competing on the highest level
because this would be impossible that
you go to the top player to the leader
just before the game it was no everybody
was focused you couldn't go near to the
players can you imagine to go near to
Kasparov and ask questions before the
game you're lucky if you could be able
to do it after the game so this is very
different than as it was before it's
it's great actually it's that the top
players are much more accessible to
every one and we can hear their thoughts
I really do like that but I completely
agree with you I do remember in the
Olympiad you know in 2002 when I saw
Gary Kasparov and he was like out of my
way and there's a game that I'm gonna
come and sit down and I'm gonna Crush my
opponent and I'm not talking to anyone
and it's not only that they're
accessible but also they are they are
helping out the media they like to show
up in the studios to discuss some of the
things to share their views their
analysis their mindset how they were
developing in the game what kind of
mistakes they are also much more honest
I must say that they are more open about
their real feelings how they felt and
what was going on and and so on which
which makes it much more interesting
sometimes to talk to them
yeah these top players they're no longer
mythical creatures that you kind of you
hear about but you never see we hear
about uh from them uh their own thoughts
and we see them all the time which we're
very lucky we're very privileged to do
so
but uh well there we have the bird's eye
view because of course we will focus
largely on the game between Hikari and
Fabiana but but there are some other
games
and how is everyone feeling I mean
taking a look at is are they in a
peaceful mood do they want to take it
out in our Armageddon do we see violence
already on the board
nothing too violent maybe we can zoom
into some of the games to check let's go
around the horn and see how all of the
openings uh have been getting on still
early days of course we're only 15
minutes into the final round here at OHS
and maybe we can start with a game key
for the standings uh towards the top
half of the table here between Wesley
Sue and gokesh a battle for second place
potentially a battle for minimum third
place and uh Wesley so with the white
pieces it doesn't look like he's been
taking too many risks so far Judith
we're kind of used to this from him by
now just very pragmatic chess very
sensible chess taking a slightly better
structure a queen trade we've just seen
happen black has just captured the White
Queen on D2 and now expecting the white
king or Knight to recapture
any chances of a weight advantage or has
go cash already solved his opening
problems well first of all I'm not
surprised at all that Wesley went into
this direction because he's a very solid
very stable player right
and not necessarily he's the guy who
wants to take huge risks at this point
in the tournament
um of course black has an isolated Pawn
on day five but it seems not a big
danger for black because let's say after
King captures the Queen Bishop takes the
pawn the D4 Pawn is controlled and black
wants to play at one point D4 at the
same time still I believe that white is
slightly better or it's more comfortable
he will be the one who is trying to
press go cash and in these kind of
positions I think of course Wesley has a
much bigger experience so nuances can be
something that gokashi is not
necessarily aware of yet
missing some experience but we'll see I
think in D2 and then Rook H to C1 makes
a lot of sense to push away the Bishop
from C5
and
and then we'll see how black will
develop further
I completely agree I mean Hikaru
actually took a very similar approach he
he navigated the position into an iqp
position with where good cash was
playing with the isolated Queen's Pawn
but the way Wesley has done it he's kind
of killed kukash's dynamism and as we
know kukash really likes to complicate
things he's excellent attacking player
so I approve of Wesley's strategy I
think actually he's being ambitious but
in a different way
yeah there's always logic behind
everything Wesley does and uh here he's
kind of taken all the risk out of the
position whether that's enough to win as
a different question but I think against
go cash who's in the form of his life no
other strategy would have been more
logical and I had some breaking news to
tease you all with Hikaru has just
dropped a confessional and it's being
edited right now
but it is quite the storyline
we'll play it for you soon so stay tuned
don't go away that's just mean teasing
us like that I had the feeling because
on the on the small video before I saw
that Nakamura left
foreign
and I had the feeling that he reached
the position where he's more or less
knows what he wanted he got it and he
sees that the Fabi is starting to think
at this point
the same time you know I'm surprised
that Wesley is thinking on how to
capture back the queen
at the same time it's an important
moment because now
it's uh deciding whether if he takes
with the Knight it means that he's going
to have his King on E2 I believe and
then possibly Knight B3
but uh well of course King D2 is the
more logical uh way of approaching this
position yeah it's more logical simply
because the Queens are off in one Fell
Swoop you can take this queen and
connect the white Rooks bring them to
the center and the white king is going
to be relatively safe in the middle of
the board despite the presence of Rooks
and minor pieces uh it feels like yeah
taking with the knights and castling the
King which a lot of you at home might be
tempted to do it will be
counter-intuitive counterproductive at
least because there your king is far
away from the action and as the end game
nears as it approaches you want your
king ready uh to kind of participate
depending where the action lies so yeah
I agreed you that I would take with the
King here without hesitation but maybe
there were small details that are making
Wesley pause
uh maybe he thinks the White Knight will
be better placed on the queen side as
you mentioned
but actually the Knight should be on
standing on F3 there is no better place
than F3 you can move it here and there
but
after after all yeah normally you want
to kind of control the square in front
of your opponent's isolated opponent
from here the Knight does control the D4
Square nicely uh so yeah classical chess
wisdom dictates that he should take with
the King and eventually after a couple
of minutes of thought Wesley does indeed
uh go for that kukesh immediately
recaptures his Pawn so level material
and this game will be a bit slower in
the near future can Wesley eke out a
small advantage
that's the big question
should we check out some of the other
openings yes and the game that I'm quite
curious because you mentioned it in the
run-up is the game between Magnus
Carlson and nordebec Abdul satoroff
because you left us with a question
which I'm dying to find out can Magnus
Carlsen get his first classical win here
in this tournament because we've
actually never seen Magnus end a
tournament with a negative score
yeah and uh also I was told that this
would be the first time since 2007 that
Magnus will have gone through a
tournament without winning a classical
game if he doesn't win this one now
against Abdul's tour of 16 years uh that
that hasn't happened
like you say Ivanka on a negative score
that would be a huge shock uh not great
for his rating either despite still
being number one on the standings
rankings there and the position we see
in front of us Queens are off the board
again Judith and actually Magnus play is
blessing this game so far it's already
Mo 15 and he spent more than a little
bit more than three minutes
there's no increment I forgot about that
and uh well it seems like a little more
pleasant for white but nothing more than
that yeah I guess you mean a little more
pleasant because long term white has the
bishop pair which could be a factor
later on exactly that's the only thing
which can make white possession better
though black is better developed for the
moment yeah like tonight ready to come
to C5 Black's Rooks ready to centralize
it looks like black is extremely active
so can Magnus make use of his Bishops
that's the key question and uh I'm going
to ask you both to guess the opening
that this one came from
and then we might do a bit of an action
replay
kind of looks like a
some weird D4 D5 thing
Judith
because this one I've actually seen this
position so I won't reveal too much but
uh when I first saw this kind of middle
game I was shocked which opening it had
come from and actually it can come from
two different openings so
I would also think it's D4 but because I
cannot imagine how it was coming from E4
okay
I will reveal all so let's jump in with
a uh with an action replay of the first
few moves uh when we're now at move 15
Magnus has been speeding up uh blitzing
up to this point and let's go back to
move one it was E4 and okay it was
actually the Petrov it started with E5
Knight F3 and after a capture of Pawns
we saw Knight F6 the Knight retreating
and white instead of uh here playing D4
or Knight C3 the main moves just gained
a Tempo by playing D3 kicking the Black
Knight back and after D4 D5 uh we
reached this symmetrical position and
this could actually be achieved much
quicker from an exchange French for
example if we go back just very briefly
uh E6 and Magnus himself after uh D5 he
went through a phase a couple of years
ago of just taking this Pawn off and
just bringing his Knight out and same
position uh just saving a couple of
moves because white hasn't had to push
his deep on black hasn't had to push
three point twice and let's go back to
the game let's see what happened in that
position after d4d5 symmetry the Bishops
came out and queen to E2 check and
Magnus is the guru in this line I
learned this line from him I used it
myself as white and he always hopes that
his opponent plays Queen E7 to me it
looks like it should be a dead draw it's
just Queens coming off the board
symmetry but Magnus always seems to win
these drier positions uh with no risk so
black instead here up to store showing
ambition not taking the Queen's off
Bishop to E6 and after Knight to G5
hitting this pint Bishop we saw Queen to
E7 and this is how we reached the game
position simply black with a slightly
backward Pawn on E6 broke out now with
E5 and the Queens came off
and Magnus after Knight bd7 he's just
played Knight F3 and this is the game
so Judy you mentioned small Advantage
let's assume black moves to this bishop
back from the center
how would you go about trying to
maintain that long term
maintains some pressure
with white
well Knight D4 seems to me that it can
be a useful move
looking a little bit to F5 to the E6
Square also Knight B5 sometimes it can
be unpleasant
at the same time black and gold Knight
G4 kind of reaction
it's a bit annoying for white
potentially if white has to spend the
time hitting your knight then at least
you can maybe there's more but at the
minimum you step back hitting the bishop
and say I Retreat you see G3 in the game
Magnus playing G3 actually I like it he
improves his King first go to G2
remember chromic giving an interview
many many years ago he said when in
doubt just play King G3 King G2 and it
always improves your position if you
have nothing else to do well good idea
yeah
and I guess he just wants to uh yeah
slowly improve King to G to bring his
Bishop out somewhere he's kind of
keeping this bishop flexible for now and
then he'll bring his Rooks to the center
how does black now uh fight long-term
white has the advantage due to those
Bishops that we mentioned but short-term
black needs some activity
well it's definitely a long-term story
and and then long term it can be very
useful to Bishop pairs
and it will take time until the bishops
from C1 develops because next move will
be Queen G2
be honest with you to me it looks
completely equal
I I don't see how white it's gonna grind
this one out I mean to do that you've
got to get motoring with the King side
pawns and you've got to put your Rooks
on the open line
but the dark Square Bishop as you
highlighted gets in the way yeah but it
will be what's the plan with white I
guess King G2 he's going to move out the
bishop somewhere to bring the Rook to D1
then eventually maybe he will even go
back to C1 Bishop C2 putting the Rooks
on the E and D file template H4
maybe bishop F5 at some point trying to
give some unpleasant checks on E6 not G5
also three six
then
[Music]
I'm loving this errors sorry I couldn't
resist it even b4a4 so you can give more
errors
exactly you you need the other side of
the board as well
but basically it's about space and and
maneuvering around the
maybe it's equal but still if somebody
can get better there's a much bigger
chance for white to get better than for
black because simply there is no no
weaknesses nothing invites a position
while for black it can easily go wrong
so it's much easier to to make mistakes
with black I believe yeah I also have
the suspicion that black probably
shouldn't trade a set of knights that
would certainly free up the bishop pair
and well we will see what happens
I'm
this is very sophisticated chess for me
so let's go back to more exciting stuff
back to the bird's eye view
and okay I we should probably take a
little Glimpse at the game between Ori
and tari and aleriza faroogia that one
looked like it came from a Sicilian
Yep this one's extremely tense only one
set of Pawn trades were already at move
13 and yeah I want your opinion on this
Judith because this is the type of
position I always struggle in where it's
just so much tension white looks like he
has the pawn Center it looks like
ariane's doing great objectively but
what to do next I never know well first
of all it's uh it's not necessarily only
Sicilian but definitely not an open
Sicilian so it's uh definitely white is
better I think or something that the an
attacker plays it with great pressure
the only thing is that that A5 bone can
be weakness after Knight C6 it can be
captured so on that white has to look
after so that's why Knight B8 was played
just in the last move to regroup it to
its C6
and well with white generally Knight F1
Knight G3 I would be going if after
Knight C6 Bishop D2 protecting the pawn
because I would not like to give that
away
um generally if I would have the time I
would be happy to play Knight F1 Queen
D3 and on Knight C6 to play Bishop D2
but it will be not enough time for white
because the A5 is uh attacked already
I often find that these type of
positions what white should do is not
get too eager and just do those piece
maneuverings that you mentioned and sit
with the space in the middle of the
board because invariably black will
always go E5 or D5 and as long as you
have a good answer to those moves
I think white is okay the only thing is
actually I don't like the pawn on A5
it's supposed to be on A3 yes covering
the square B4 and now I really don't
like the fact that right if if white
goes away to F1 then Knight C6 Bishop D2
and even immediately D5 can be a very
strong breaking out after E5 sacrificing
upon with Knight E4
to put this on the boardroom yes yeah
this is what I wanted to suggest that
maybe we can see it first of all
immediately D5 is also possible
but also Knight C6 and Bishop D2 going
D5 because uh
E5 Knight E4 I was thinking
and this is the thing if black gets too
active even here it looks like a French
defense Pawn structure but suddenly it's
a dream French defense black species
just very active as mentioned in white
it's just one move too slow to stop this
Black Knight infiltrating into the
center and actually I completely
understand why tari decided to go Knight
B3 because he was really afraid of his
Pawn to be lost on A5 but it's not
standing so nice
Knight B3 instantly met by Knight C6
black has ideas as well of jumping into
B4 harassing this white light squared
Bishop so due to how to or Ivanka how to
deal with this I
I don't know it just feels a bit loose
to me for white uh even if the pawn
Center is beautiful I agree because your
idea of D5 and jumping in with the
Knight to E4 still very much on the
cards
and
Bishop D2 yeah just to show uh this idea
we should also mention that the Knight
can be captured some viewers at home
might be wondering oh why can't white
win a pawn but here there are tactics
I'm assuming I believe yeah this Rook is
going to be hit and The Rook could slide
maybe hoping to Checkmate the black king
G4
threatening or hinting at Bishop H6
these types of things might happen but
black has full control of the light
Square so if white doesn't check mate
then things might might uh backfire
later on
well black can even go just rookie 8 I
believe I mean there's quite a good
compensation having a B7 Bishop there
yeah
there's peace on the board but maybe
there is something better maybe it's too
early to play D5 and Knight E4 in this
case because Knight on B3 is not only
defending the A5 Pawn but also in some
cases after D5 the C5 Square can be
vulnerable for black
yeah so patient waiting game maybe uh in
store instead I just put this bishop D2
on the board I was just scared of the
Black Knight jumping into beat the B4
square but I think it's a very logical
move by the way yeah
what else what's the question well you
can also go Bishop F4 for example to
develop
okay Bishop F4 as well
and if Knight B4 then simply Bishop B1
and then the Knight on B4 is not doing
too much
just hanging in the air and I can play
Bishop D2 in a later stage and push you
back ah sneaky gaining unless you go now
with the five five yeah D5 and after E5
Knight E4 and this is already not a pawn
sacrifice yeah defended this Knight
indirectly with the bishop yeah these
positions they could open up they could
just explode at some point or they could
just turn in one side's favor well
Knight F3 to D2 trying to
get rid of the E4 Knight
I think maybe D5 is kind of early for
black
maybe he has to play simply after Knight
B4 Bishop B1 playing Queen C7
ideas such as this just trying to jump
in with a black knight invade Knight C2
is a threat now
yeah in in general times do you think in
the current position in the game
position for Russia is he still in
preparation he's played extremely
quickly up to this point normally he
tanks a bit more in the opening normally
he kind of tries to Freestyle a bit more
I'm not sure that he's so much into the
concrete preparation I'm pretty sure
that he knows the ideas and he
understands that okay if the phone on A5
I have this Knight B8 Knight C6 kind of
idea I will put my pieces here and there
but whether it's a Concrete position
that he prepared I'm not sure
hence game with a lot of play and I
think it's the perfect time to take a
breather take a rest and take our very
first break
and we will play the Hikaru confessional
during the break so watch out for that
one to all the subscribers but for now
let's mention the officialchess.com
Community Club this is the place to be
for all info on community tournaments
giveaways contests and other events plus
connect with the community and stay up
to date on the Chess World use s-clamp
community in chat to get in on the
action and now over to our fourth
commentator from the booth Hikaru
Nakamura take it away
um welcome back everybody so today of
course final day here at Norwich has
round number nine and I'm playing with
the white piece against Fabiano now
obviously today there are only a couple
of games that really are important I
guess you could say towards the
standings uh basically Wesley's game
against gukesh and my game against
Fabiano pretty much everything else is
relevant
um Wesley's game against Google cash
looks pretty normal standard Queens game
decline we'll see what Wesley intends I
think might have surprised by playing
the C5 variation Wes is going to look
for some small advantage in some line or
probably make a draw of one of the two
options um but that's pretty early now
as far as my game of course I'm gonna
wax uh wax poetic a little bit I guess
you could say or be a little bit of a
philosopher here so what I'm playing
today is something that I've not played
in in a very very long time over 14 plus
years since I played this bishop D3 line
against Joshua friedel in the final
round of the 2009 us Championship that
of course a very sort of I guess
memorable and important moment in my
chest Square for a couple of reasons
first of all it was the first year that
the US Championship was held in St Louis
it was a first event major event that
Rex sinkfield was sponsoring at the time
and in the final round there were two
players tie for first there was myself
alongside Bobby Hess Rob Grand Master
Robert has of course the famous guy you
know you can't spell chess without Hess
um who maybe is doing commentary today
that would be kind of funny but we're
both tied tied for first place going to
the last round and then final round I
had the white pieces against Josh
Riddell and Robert I believe had the
white pieces or maybe was a black
because I think it was against Yuri
Shulman if I remember correctly at any
rate Robert would draw his game I won a
very nice game in relatively short
fashion um to become the US champion
so it's very memorable because of the
fact it was first tournament in St Louis
also it's very memorable for me
personally because when I when I look
back on that tournament
many players were playing her played in
St Louis they would be able to relate to
this but this was before there had been
this establishment I guess you could say
there weren't really the hotels these
accommodations and so I was actually
staying downtown in St Louis I remember
a long time trainer who's here with me
right now Chris Littlejohn he um he
basically brought his he brought his
desktop from or the tower from Dallas
Texas he drove in a rental car all the
way to St Louis we're staying at the
Hilton in the downtown area and I
remember going to the last round I
really wasn't sure what I was going to
do and and at that at that point I
basically
um before going to the final round I
went to bed relatively early I would say
and I told Chris just find something in
E4 E5 and this is actually what he came
up with he came with the idea based off
of one game that was played by morosevic
before but certainly after I played that
game this whole variation became very
prominent and it's considered a main
line so I'm really excited to be able to
play it after after so many years I
would also blend it together with
another thing that I wanted to say
yesterday which is on the rest day we
went to this this island majority are
there however you pronounce it I'm not
going to pretend to be our antari um
with this pronunciation but uh there was
a picture that I took with chakra there
and
um you know it's one of these things
where at the end of the day when you
play all these different tournaments you
know you compete against these guys over
and over and over years and years and
years go by
um but it's all sort of like it all sort
of Blends together and I was thinking
like whether this you have shamsha
whether chakra it's many many years like
we all are sort of in have the same
lifestyle we all end up spending time
together and so uh it's it's it becomes
very nostalgic at a certain point as
well so we're going to see what happens
in my game today is obviously different
from my game against free dial but thus
far at least I feel pretty good I have a
feeling we're probably going to Blitz
out another 10 plus moves which is why I
don't mind standing here and wasting
five to ten minutes of my time since I
assume Fabian have probably moved pretty
quickly but we will see I'll be back
later
thank you
[Music]
foreign
chess where the action is all happening
everything will be decided today and
during the break well you all heard
Hikaru in the confessional Booth telling
us his thoughts as to why he chose this
opening whoa it seemed like Hikaru was
feeling a very sentimental there and uh
almost it felt like he was acknowledging
the efforts and hard work that his
second Chris Littlejohn Little John has
uh put into helping Hikaru rise to the
top
yeah they've been together what is it
around 15 years that story that game was
14 years ago where his second came up
with this idea uh kind of worked on this
idea fine-tuned it and wow Hikaru
digging through past glories there he
might have found the recipe for Success
because actually just as we jump back in
Fabiana has made a mistake and quite
significant one we see on the camera
Hikaru frowning for the first time in
this game he's out of preparation but
normally that means alarm Bells going
through the head the reason this
position this move was not in hikara's
preparation is because it wasn't one of
the top computer suggestions
and I'm sure Chris Littlejohn fed Hikaru
some nice ideas here but I think Hikaru
doesn't need nice ideas he just has a
very simple move he's about to go two
pawns up Judith what is Fabi doing just
lashing out now with the move F5
yeah it's a very concrete uh move that
it's kind of aggressive and it forces
white pushing white to give take the
pawn on C5 right
and the question is whether after Knight
takes C5 black wants to go Queen A5 that
seems to be the the most logical
continuation and I have to figure out
also what's going on but maybe white can
go Knight A4
leaving the bishop behind on A3 because
then Rook C6
this is one of the idea maybe we can
jump in to show this we should mention
question mark attached to Black's last
move meaning a mistake is significantly
made of Happy's position worse that's
confirmed and we just have to understand
why Hikaru is trying to figure out why
Judith let's go through your line Knight
takes pawn and now a double attack
hitting this bishop and also there's a
pin along this diagonal and you
mentioned maybe white can simply retreat
well that was my idea yeah I don't know
if this is the best one yeah Bishop
takes Bishop can happen Rook takes
Knight and white is still two pawns up
black I guess we'll get some
compensation
with his Bishop for the long diagonal
but feels like white should be for
Choice here but you know there is
another way of making uh progress maybe
for white if we don't go here but Knight
C5 Queen A5 and what about going Bishop
B2 back but that's probably not good
which takes Knight yeah I thought after
Bishop takes Queen C2 but that's uh I
think not a good one because Knight B4
is also possibility like before and if
the Queen's come off the board at the
very end
whoops there's a night fork and uh black
regains some of the material
but so many loose pieces for black you
get the feeling uh I mean we have the
evaluation bar so we know but you get
the feeling at least uh instinctively
that something's going wrong for black
in that variation Queen to A5 the key
the critical moment for Fabi but we
still have to see if after Knight C5 why
the bar is going up to the Rook today
I was also looking at the possibilities
against the black king
it's on an open diagonal yeah maybe
Queen C2 so I thought Queen C2 that's
the move Queen C2
again
okay no I don't know still gives a
pretty hefty Advantage for white uh the
even the computer here is confused uh
but it does settle down on White's side
so let's see on Queen A3 E3 Queen C4
check engage eight Knight G5 five yeah
threatening the old smothered mate my
favorite Checkmate David let's just show
this on the board Bishop takes Knight
for example uh black tries to escape
then night check talk us through your
favorite Checkmate Ivanka oh it's very
beautiful the king will move to G8 and
then this is very important put this one
in your memory banks and that comes to
the edge of the board and the King has
to run to h8 because if you go to f8 the
queen will come to F7 Checkmate and here
you just uh give away your queen
Quinta G8
boom yeah close the cage exactly and
that poor old King is trapped in the
corner and that's how you smother the
king with just your knight this is this
is also one of my favorites too I even
have a skirt having this Checkmate on it
I will show you
I want a skirt with with a smothered
mate on it
I was going into a show and it was
designed special They asked what is your
favorite
pattern inches okay
this looks potentially very strong for
White Queen to C2 if Queen takes Bishop
a check the evaluation bar did drop
though however after Knight to G5 yes
because what about H6 yeah just creating
a Luft square and Escape Square for the
black king on H7 so a check can be
simply be met by I have to tell you that
this bar is really irritates me it's
like like I'm making an awful move I
make a good move it's like it's like
we're asking the teacher for permission
and if we make a bad move if we give the
wrong answer it's like no no no
but yeah it seems like no no no this
time I think it represents what Hikaru
is calculating he'll look at this line
and he even in his mind he'll be like oh
I think it works no it doesn't no it
doesn't and then he decides just like
the bar is deciding and uh kind of we
have that shortcut we have that life
hack there but Hikaru doesn't have that
of course available to him so Queen C2 I
mean it looks like we're on the right
lines oh sorry in this position and then
we need a knockout blow for white
to justify this peace sacrifice Hikaru
needs to find a way what about Queen F7
attacking this Rook
computer says no
hmm
BlackRock will move I guess
or maybe the bishop but you know what
there is Queen D5
aha maybe Queen D5
pin and win the Knight is pinned to The
Rook no way to defend it wow
that is a rare pattern indeed yeah not
the simple move to
notice yeah now for example Bishop takes
Knight I guess what we'll take this one
and Fork the two black Rooks as well as
this bishop next move and at the very
end white will emerge at least two pawns
up
absolutely wow so this could be one of
the reasons why uh Fabiano has just made
a mistake F5 on the board the last move
we can see with the question mark Knight
to C5 must be the way to refute this if
you step back if you step to any other
Square it feels like you've worsened
your piece for example if you step back
I mean here there's plenty of moves I'm
very tempted I'm very attracted to just
planting the queen in the middle of the
board for black and it looks like black
has a decent amount of control decent
amount of competition for the sacrificed
Pawn
now we have to look into Knight C5 to
continue to discover what are the
opportunities for black
for compensation at the same time after
Knight C5 two pawns down for Fabi
yeah what else do you play again you
could play Move like Queen D5 maybe you
could make an argument for taking this
Knight and just putting your Bishop on
B7 but that's not why he's given up a
second point but the thing is after
Queen D5 right should be probably
playing anyway Queen C2 with the plan of
Queen C4 and exchanging the Queens
yeah
coupons up and and the Knight just
completely dominates the light squared
Bishop
yeah the Knight
it's normally the other way around it's
normally a bishop that kind of controls
a knight but here uh this Bishops here
cannot get out
yeah this is uh Fabi playing for Content
this is a crazy position and and if we
were going back to Knight takes C5 and
and Judith mentioned Queen A5
say
you played uh is there a kind of
we've been looking at Queen C2 but I
just wonder whether that's the only move
to give the advantage is there anything
like
I don't know Knight A4 was another move
we suggested I just wondered whether
that's maybe that G5 is possible Knight
G5 yes yes yes yes yes yes Knight G5 wow
oh and not only Queen H5 but Queen F3
oh all the attacks
oh that's a killer finally we found what
the bar wanted from us
now the question is whether Nakamura
finds this uh idea and it's not
surprising actually uh in the fried
liver attack in general uh Black's King
is a Target and white tonight has
already been to this Square uh so maybe
the hardest visual thing is to spot that
you bring it back and queen H5 the first
killer threat as Judith mentions Queen
F3 as well and yeah if you take this
bishop just to show this on the board
the Queen comes out this is Checkmate in
one threatened only one way to deal with
this and if you push your Pawn then okay
white will give a check for example and
take the black Rook Black's house is
collapsing
G5 H6 is white going to play Queen F3 or
queen H5
sorry just let me find this one not here
my G5 H6
then the question is is it the queen H5
or queen F3
one of these two you either hit the Rook
or you hit the Knight
both look extremely H5
first The Rook is the heavier piece
let's attack that Fabby getting away
looking calm but I don't know if he
realizes what he's done yet did
and if you made the move he he made a
Grimace ah you saw it on the camera yeah
wow and
he understood that it wasn't the correct
move at all
maybe as soon as he made the move he
spotted Nike firefin
it's a slippery slope once you make one
mistake here you're pretty much
committed and uh you can also see Hikaru
also made a frown as well somehow are
there spider senses are just like
tingling away saying this is the moment
to burn the energy and figure out the
correct way
and just while her car is thinking just
while uh we're still on this game we
talked about the fried liver attack if
we backtrack the whole way back to the
opening uh to show this after e45 one of
the most uh kind of principled but also
one of the most controversial moves in
this position Knight to G5 does start
this and we're talking about seeing
Knight G5 in the game position as maybe
a potential winner here Knight G5 after
D5 this is a trick that everyone at home
needs to know Knight takes D5 looks like
a natural move you defend this Knight
you kind of block this bishop but it
will be disaster on the light squares
just as it might be in the game that
we're seeing right now Knight takes F7
is the killer move for white here
there's been a lot of analysis on this
you kind of lure the blacking out onto a
vulnerable diagonal just as it is in the
game and this is a deadly double attack
you hit the Knight but this check is the
key Black's King can walk out of course
into the open but this position is just
too strong for white here this I think
D4 there's castles but either way this
black king shouldn't survive yeah
incidentally my dad had me playing this
opening with black and I was like I
really don't want to play with my king
out there and he goes it's fine trust me
and incidentally fried liver kind of an
unusual name for an opening but we well
we asked and our producer big he
listened and he says that fried liver is
Italian way of cooking liver
fecatello I think means to put the liver
in a net and cook it over a fire or in
modern times drink it with Chianti
wow now we're all learning today no no I
added that little bit because doesn't he
say fried liver with some Chianti
probably
Silence of the Lambs taking notes it's
been a while since I watched that one I
I couldn't watch that film
yeah
shoot it do you think he's going to find
this sequence Hikaru surely process of
elimination the first move is where he's
looking well this is full of drama what
is going on right now and Fabi knows it
he left the board not to go to the
confessional booth
Professor he's somewhere in the in the
background trying to figure out how he
will react on Knight C5
but because everything became so weak
right that after Knight C5 if Queen A5
then simply the G5 square is uh
unprotected anymore it left free for the
right night and everything is hanging
after Queen A5 for black also they see
six Knight and the E8 Rook so I don't
know after Knight C5 how can black go
further and look for a compensation
I think he might just have to admit he's
two pawns down and just continue playing
maybe just take that Knight off the
board and
yeah but let's say if you take Knight
off the board and Rook C5 maybe a third
Point drops and the E5 Pawn is also weak
exactly yeah so this is why F5 is uh is
so bad because it even weakens the E5
you will not be able to play E4
or uh
because after Knight C5 Bishop C5 Rook
C5 it comes with the tempo yeah it's
like you said everything is weak the C5
Pawn is immediately weak the E5 Pawn has
become weak the king
obviously has opened up on the diagonals
and also the pawn on F5 gets in the way
of the bishop on C8 I mean that Bishop
wants to be out there on G4 yeah I guess
this is why they do say develop your
pieces before you start pushing too many
pawns and here most of blacks pieces on
the back rank they're not ready for this
action to happen yeah but at the same
time I don't know exactly what
blackheads which he should have done
instead of f4 because F5 because C5 bond
is under attack it is going to be taken
actually there were some games in the
database and black hadors responded to
this uh if you take back F5 let's jump
in blackhead responded with two moves
and uh one was to go night before
and I guess Target the A2 born and
Target the D3 Pawn the other move was
actually to pin the Knight on F3 with
Bishop G4
also logical continuation after Bishop
G4 Knight D4 is a threat
yeah this would be extremely logical uh
but Fabi he also went for logical moves
for all of the kind of best options here
seem to be kind of threatening moves
attacking moves but unfortunately he
just went maybe a bit too loose
and that could backfire imagine a
tournament being decided by one move F5
in a roughly balanced position just
lashing out and Knight takes C5 we think
is decisive huge huge Advantage for
Hikaru Nakamura
I was wondering you know because
obviously Fabi has a lot of emotion
right now especially if he realizes that
he's made a mistake and yes it's good to
kind of sit down and work out all those
lines and the best defensive move but is
it good to kind of also go to the
confessional and go
ah
no way no
you don't want to share your painful
moments I would be in there just sobbing
crying my eyes out just thinking what
have I done but also the fact you
mentioned Ivanka you think Fabi has
realized the fact he's gone back down to
sit at the board that could be giving a
lot away just I mean it's so hard to
maintain a poker face
if you just Flinch once if you kind of
kind of Grimace once your opponent will
spot that and kind of their Spidey
senses will tingle and
I don't know I would walk away the way
Naka is playing like he's nodding his
head it's like this this yes yes yes
very good
he does that a lot a lot on stream and
it's always when he knows he's winning
he's calculating a long variation and
he's coming to that conclusion that it
all works
a streamer
he could just wow win this one within a
couple of hours if he plays Knight take
C5 and has worked let's go into Knight
C5
and queen D5 let's jump back in I take
C5 Queen to D5 just trying to hold
things together and you mentioned this
queen to C2 move through that trying to
trade off these heavy pieces the Queens
try to utilize the extra two Pawns in
the end game
and
it's just hard to find a backup a
follow-up
what to play right
incredibly tough for black I mean you
can take this Knight as mentioned but
it's always being replaced by a equally
strong piece White Queen will take back
and
Flex position collapsing
yeah it's also easy to react on uh and
okay if not Queen D5 but let's say yeah
yeah of course Queen A5 is and he's
taking it oh
it's about to take the spawn let's go
back to the game position
yeah the fried liver attack I must admit
fond memories for me in this Pawn
structure uh with these Double D pawns I
think one of my best ever games was from
the white side not this exact line but
the same Pawn structure and
also happened because my opponent played
the move at five I think it's just
generally inadvisable until your pieces
are fully ready
okay Moment of Truth do you think he'll
come up with a quick sequency card
playing Knight takes C5 and he's worked
everything out well first of all the the
big question is how far baby will be
reacting on Knight C5 is he going to be
playing I don't know Queen B6 or or
making a move uh instantly maybe F4 and
play Bishop G4 I don't know what he he
can come up with right
because the big problem is after Knight
C5 is not only that you have two pawns
down but the problem is that the C8
Bishop cannot develop
to G4 it cannot because F5 Pawn is
blocking but the B7 Square would be very
important for the bishop to look for
counter play on the long diagonal and
that's also not possible only if you
take on C5 takes Bishop C7 you give up
the third pawn and then you're praying
that somehow you you want to get some
counter play maybe we can go there
okay what happens if Knight C5 Bishop C5
Rook C5 let's jump in and uh Bishop B7
let's say I naively grab a third Pawn
I'm not sure that's a good move maybe
but okay go take it
yeah take it I don't need that pawn
channeling my inner Ivanka
that's a gun ID for Knight D4 yeah so
you want to ideally check make me on G2
Sunday
hmm
but I didn't see a threat I mean I
attempt to just step back and manage
this Knight still touch to go for
checkmate against the black king let's
say I just kind of control I'll drop
back
all the bar drops it went G5 is it yeah
to stop Queen G5 that made me a bit
nervous
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm very nervous
well it's still it's still I don't know
I need to request the tape back
Grant it yeah suddenly some counter play
maybe this is the best bet for uh Fabian
practical terms objectively of course
the three pawns down it shouldn't be
sufficient that since we are analyzing
this position after F5 this is the best
we got yeah
at least an active Bishop an active
Knight for now
come at the cost of three pawns you go
Queen C1 what do you think about that
and queen C4 idea oh that's deep we're
just fixated now on this queen C4 idea
but it seems extremely strong still
ideas of smothered mates as you showed
Ivanka
all of these lines just not working out
and uh suddenly we see Fabby head in
hands trying to block his uh direct
Vision with Hikaru and Hikaru he's done
the right thing and this is again just
great tip for everyone at home like when
your instincts tell you something's up
or something's changed or something's
different uh if you have a feeling that
you're winning take a pause because
normally that's just the brain's way of
uh indirectly telling you that it's a
critical moment
it is a critical moment and there on the
right we can see the prize money at
stake and of course the prices are
listed in Norwegian Corona so all you
have to do is divide that by 10 and then
you get the amount in dollars although
the Norwegian krona
it's it's dipping it's crashing
good time to be alive annoy but
meanwhile okay Knight takes Pawn on C5
it is on the board and we're going to
have a confessional from Nakamura what
it thinks about Knight F Knight C5
yeah and Fabiano is going into the tank
he got up with purpose there Hikaru is
like yeah he just kind of stretched out
and he's like okay I've got this it's so
close now
uh do you think he's worked out Queen A5
that he's winning there Knight G5 I
think he had to because after Queen A5
there is not much of a choice for white
and the Knight A4 was the only well not
the only move because we've seen Queen
C2 also possible the queen C2 had a very
difficult Twist of spotting the Knight
on C6 yes could be attacked with the
queen on D5 I think it's much more
natural to go Knight G5 and once you see
it yeah it becomes obvious but it took
him a while to confirm in his mind and
welcome back chat yeah somehow other
I've got like Monty Python in my head
Life of Brian it's a miracle it's
happened I mean fabi's made a mistake I
mean but fabi's so good so it just must
have been
over excitement yeah fabi's the one that
needs a miracle now yeah but don't don't
forget that before F5 position it is
exactly a position you don't want to
have then your opponent is in a must it
must be in situation and and you have to
make a draw I mean it has so much
Dynamic and it's a it's really awful to
have a pawn down and that you have to
play in every single move the best move
to keep on your compensation
so it was an incredible fantastic choice
by Nakamura playing uh this line and uh
yeah Chad's saying my heart is singing
for nakikaru but my soul is crying for
Fabian when you see Fabi deep in
thoughts and you can actually feel the
suffering I mean yeah my heart is
actually crying for him I really
I am actually praying for miracle for
both sides
chess is such a cruel mistress she's I
mean here the chest God's frowning on
Fabi such a good tournament he's played
superbly so smooth most of the games and
it might just come down to one slip one
blunder yeah okay and I think this is uh
after that Sensational moment that in
the game I think it's a good time to
take it to another break because there
is another five minute confessional from
Hikaru where he's made some very big
Revelations not only in his games but
also his future over the board plans so
Hikaru take it away
yeah so I decided to come back pretty
quickly this time just because I'm a
little bit bored frankly um I don't
really have a lot extra ad but you know
I was thinking about the the game so far
and um just in general I mean as I as I
said in the game between gookash and
Wesley Wesley's trading the Queens he's
gonna look for a small Advantage
um but I find it hard to believe there's
anything there the other games however
some things are happening so Magnus and
gaming gives note Rebecca's noteworthy
for a few reasons
but first and foremost as we know Magnus
uh has been been playing a lot of Blitz
online the last couple of days he's
actually been doing what what sometimes
I used to do when I had bad bad results
in classical top level uh tournaments
where when I was doing poorly I would
just started playing a lot of Blitz
online all night long to try and get it
out of my system or maybe motivate
myself find some confidence and I know
over the last like two nights
specifically or maybe maybe it wasn't
last night when he played knee-haul but
a MAG has been playing a lot of Blitz
online so I think Magus is looking for
something but the problem of course is
that it looks like notorbeck is
completely prepared for what madness has
played in the opening in his game and
again doesn't look like Magnus is a
whole lot
so that that game is looking fairly
fairly balanced um shotgun on each are
playing something weird in this Knight
G7 uh Spanish with D4 takes and Knight
C6 I'm not sure what's going on but long
way to go and then we also have tari
versus faroosh of course alireza wants
to win this game because for everybody
who's not named me there is this thing
called the candidates on the line and
potentially the second spot could
qualify for the candidates by raiding if
Magnus chooses not to play so we're like
Ollie Rose and Fabiano there's a lot
more on the line potentially than me in
the situation
um I think I said I mean I don't know if
I said this but again I'm sticking to my
schedule I may or may not play a chart
here or there but most likely I won't
qualify for the candidates simply
because I won't play enough tournaments
in the year but it is what it is so I
don't know if I've said that but more or
less I'm just going on my Merry way you
know marching to my own drum beat uh
drummer who marches his own or the drama
march to his own beat or whatever
whatever I was saying is I can't
remember right off um
so so yeah so all the games I mean are
happening my game with Fabiano of course
I'm waiting to see which one he plays
her there I've looked at I think four
different moves in this position I'm not
sure which one he's gonna play at the
end of the day um there are some move
order tricks because there's some lines
where black plays C5 and white goes
Knight E4 their other lines were C5 you
go Bishop A3 so there's some little move
order nuances depending on what Fabiana
chooses to do
um he's using a lot of time and I think
he's going to continue to use time here
because the move orders are very
critical since at the moment I am
currently up a pawn if I can get rid of
this double Pawn potentially I can claim
an advantage down the road so it's a
it's a sort of a very critical moment in
the game right now I think um Fabiano
likely we'll use 20 minutes or more on
this move just to make sure of his move
orders um the good thing is he's
thinking which means he has not looked
at us a little bit afraid that he might
have looked at this potentially for his
earlier game against Notre back a couple
rounds back but it appears he didn't
look at this specifically which is a
good thing because I did actually look
at this for Notre back yesterday prior
to the game again so I thought motorbike
might play this Knight G5 which of
course if black plays D5 takes 95 we of
course know it as the fried liver so um
and no I did not make that up that is
the actual name so
um fabian's gonna probably use a bit of
time it's good that he didn't look at
this you know to give you a contrast uh
to the last time I was like in a similar
situation a bit big moment big
tournament you know I played against
Dingle around in the final round of the
candidates and I remember that going
into that game Dean was trying to figure
out where could he surprise me where
would surprise come with the white
pieces and as soon as I blitzed out my
opening which was the semi semi-tourage
um he had this look of like
disappointment like huh I picked the
wrong thing so from the general
standpoint when you're in a final round
game where you desperately need to win
to try and to try time when the
tournament or qualifier whatever it
might be if you're able to surprise your
opponent that's the best possible start
that you can get and so I've gotten that
thus far which of course bodes very I
mean very well it's way too optimistic
but definitely the best that I could
have expected thus far considering how
solid a player Fabiano is and we'll just
have to wait and see what happens
um from here on out but as I said I
think he's going to use a lot of time
maybe he already moved maybe I'm maybe
I'm just standing here for forever or
not and just losing time on the clock
but again so far at least it's all
preparation and I feel pretty good
um but yeah it's pretty much like I feel
like it's it's Do or Die situation kind
of need to go for it try to win this
game you know a la of course all the
sports teams right now like uh as I
think people know I live in Florida and
I went to one of the one of the playoff
hockey games a couple weeks back before
I came here for Norwood chest hopefully
I'll get back in time to go to game six
and watch the Panthers win the cup of
course now that I say that maybe I'll
drink something uh they want you know a
nice overtime game last night to bring
the series back to two to one but sort I
feel like right now it's a sporting
aspect where it's like it's all in just
keep the game going try to win uh
because a draw does nothing for either
side and I'm feeling great and I'm just
really really excited uh to be where I'm
at and I mean if you told me before the
turn I'd be here I probably would have
said no chance I'd be playing for first
place in the final round I just have a
solid result and that's that but things
seem to be working out and um it's it's
all it's all good it's all it's all as
they say I'm just I'm playing with house
money right now so it's all Gratis
anyway see you guys
foreign
giving us his deepest thoughts there in
the confessional and I like the way it
all sounds it started with a summary of
the other games and then it kind of
moved on to something very personal
about how maybe he's not going to be
playing too many games to qualify to the
candidates and uh then very cheerfully
feeling very positive about his position
and that was the moment probably before
F5
yes we are probably in for confessional
part three yes absolutely after F5 but
you know what I was I was thinking of
that he he told us that he was preparing
against Noddy Burke with the other side
being on the black side against this
Gambit or this the system the the fried
liver and maybe it gave the idea to him
yesterday
that well actually it's not even so
simple for black and then maybe it came
to the idea that ah so then tomorrow I
play this with white
inspired him yeah yeah just uh often I
mean there's just too many chess
openings out there these days and
sometimes you need a little kind of
nudge like that in the right direction
you see oh one of your opponents has
played this with success you use it and
hit you around and that's paying off
Hikaru I mean it was interesting what
did you think not kind of overly fussed
about playing the candidates qualifying
for the world championship match he
mentioned the game against Dean glassy
and the candidates if he drew that one
of course he would have had his shot at
the world title he would have played Yan
the punishi do you think it's just not a
priority for him right now
well it's very clear that being a
streamer is is a priority I mean we see
it also in this tournament that during
the game he is using the confessional
boost for streaming
and Entertainer or our audience as he
knows that he's good at it and also that
it pleases the the Enthusiast fans of
him and the viewers I think of of the
show
but but he did say in the Norway chess
conference that the streaming and this I
don't care I literally don't care
philosophy is helping him a lot with his
chess because to him okay he loses not a
big deal he moves on to the next game
and uh the emotions surrounding and
nerves surrounding those big moments are
not there anymore so he can simply go on
his merry way and March to the beat of
his own drum
you nailed the phrase there
yeah it seems like that beat is going
pretty well for Hikaru so far and wow
imagine winning this tournament
pretty much semi-retired and just
crushing everyone when he comes back
meanwhile while Fabi picks apart the
ruins of his position tries to find any
Solace there should we do a quick Round
Up of the other games
yes yeah one game that I'm intrigued by
is uh the clash between Annie shigiri
and mamajarov we haven't actually uh
been able to follow that one so far
we've had about 12 moves so far in that
game after one hour and 12 minutes of
play
so maybe we can start that and then
we'll do a quick Roundup of the other
games before uh checking in on how
fabi's doing so this is the current
position
um should we do a quick recap how we got
here uh let's do a quick action replay
it started as a Spanish as the Roy Lopez
uh Bishop E5 met by my favorite Blitz
move Knight G E7 I don't trust it I
think it's a bit too provocative but
there are some ideas that black has
there's played not the first time yeah
this is true he often adds A6 as well
kind of beforehand there's some key
differences if The Bishop's on A4 or not
uh in this line but Anish met this very
directly I'm surprised by this Anish D4
and after a bunch of exchanges takes
takes takes takes uh Knight C6 hitting
the White Queen and after the queen
retreated we see this move from
mamajarov really kind of I would want to
say clever Knight B4 it's also very
direct heading to C2 Pawn threatening a
nasty fork in that square forcing
White's Queen back to an even clumsier
post and after the move C6 kicking the
white Bishop pack this is the current
position Queen to D1 and Rook E8 White's
Queen has moved four times at this early
stage
but black has lost a lot of time as well
it's not it's not only that four times
but it went back to its initial Square I
know
that was so quite unique if it would be
standing on G3 or H5 let's say or even
F4 I would understand the effort you
know but
it's like you're doing a workout but
you're not actually going out the door
and running you're just jogging on the
spot running on the spot don't knock
that David sorry I'm sure that's a Bible
Way of burning those calories uh that
White Queen though
quite the journey
and okay what do we make of the
resulting position here uh just started
the mid the middle game both sides have
castled looks to me like white should
have a small Advantage due to the kind
of extra space in the center but
I'm not sure how much that is White's
Bishop developed now Anish very sensible
with
Judith would you take white or black
well at first it seems like I would
rather play it with the white and of
course after Bishop F4 finally the queen
can make its fifth move to D2 to prepare
The Rook move to D1 and it will be
pressing the D6 Pawn so the question is
I think whether can black play D5 in
this position because otherwise white
can go Bishop D6 or even play E5 at some
point and don't allow the D7 Pawn to
break out anymore so black definitely
has to react D6 D5 Bishop CC Bishop F6
the bishop F6 seems to me that it's uh
pretty shaky because after that Bishop
D6 would be occupying that square and it
would be very difficult for black to
come out
so I believe D6 or D5 yeah before this
becomes a real backward Pawn on D7 uh
yeah it feels like he wants to lash out
it's also mataj style to play Move Like
D5 if it works
the only thing is that after D5 I would
want to play A3 and as that Knight what
are you doing there
go back to the Rim Yeah from there we'll
go to C5
should we jump and just show this one
variation before we continue our Roundup
absolutely a key moment here if black
can't play D5 then it might be a severe
disadvantage strategically you want to
kick away this Black Knight and first of
all do I Retreat or do I counter-attack
maybe I counter-attack Against
whitesnite
is this possible yeah this is what that
was calculating what about a takes B4
latex C3 and the Queen
uh I don't even take on d8 I go B takes
E3 because if I take on d8 you take with
the bishop and you open up for the Rooks
row to E4 yeah so uh the takes takes
takes ends here no Queen takes Pawn uh
Queen takes queen that instead we take
this Pawn Yeah
and
yeah how does black
fight back temporarily upon down this
annoying pin on the a file
the engine the evaluation bar at least
says it's level but I just see how
immediately
hmm
let's say I trade the Queens yeah Rook F
takes D1
and on Bishop F6 E5 was the plan maybe I
can start with the move G5 just to give
my king some space but you know what
maybe you do play Bishop F6 uh-huh
which was six and after E5 Bishop G
Bishop F5 aha because this Pawn is
pinned in the center there's so many
tactics despite it being reduced now to
Rooks and Bishops left on the board
and after he takes F6 rookie two Rook A5
double attack that's annoying no
succeeded to get two pawns down yeah
everything is hanging unfortunately I
can't take a rook I love that line where
he said no let's not do that with her
mermaid's position yeah the pawn counts
alone is uh not too important because
it's opposite color Bishops it's just
more the tactics that work in White's uh
favor here so I was thinking maybe we
start with the move G5 just to give the
black king some breathing space and only
once you decide what to do with this
bishop for example if you step back now
Bishop F6 and E5 is less powerful
because the black king will never get
checkmated on the back rank well I guess
after G5 I will have to bring back the
bishop to D2
to defend the C3 or to E3
but you yeah
and now I think again and I'm not sure
what to do
um yeah I mean this I think is this type
of position at least that Mama jarov is
mulling over contemplating does he have
enough compensation for the pawn if he
in the game position plays D5 then it
looks like we're forced down these lines
it's going to become extremely extremely
kind of uh forcing the nature of the
play
okay
so uh tense a game there should we go
back to the bird's eye view because
Hikaru actually specifically mentioned
two names obviously Fabiano was one of
them and then he also mentioned that for
alireza it was probably a very important
game because being number two in the
world rankings
is actually very important when it comes
to qualifying for the candidates
yeah there might be a rating spot on the
line uh for the candidates tournament
there certainly was in the past that's
how ding got in uh he needed to play a
lot of games last minute but he got
through on rating and later became world
champion
and alireza as black he's also playing
the tail Ender Arie antari who's had a
tough couple of days uh tough fortnite
actually here in Stavanger
and this position has changed slightly
the pawn structure has clarified or at
least black has made a big decision to
put a Pawn on E5 what do we make of this
well the main achievement or the main
happening what was happening is that the
Bishop from C1
went to G3 through the road of Bishop G5
H4 and G3 right
and that's a big question whether is it
placed very well there and of course
that after E5 there is a great
opportunity for white to go Knight H4
and Knight F5
and this way that the bishop Point G3
the black C6 Knight is tied down to the
E5 Pawn for the moment
yeah so you're happy to keep the tension
in the center uh as white I guess
another big question is whether to take
whether to block whether to just leave
it not touch anything in the middle of
the board
I think for now it's quite fine for a
white to keep the tension and in some
occasions maybe D5 though I would not be
very happy with the bishop on G3 moving
the pawn forward to e to D5 it's more
about keeping the tension
yeah it looks like D5 is bad for all
four Bishops on the bud just none of
those Bishops will be happy if the
center gets locked up yes because after
the five kind of positions the bishop
should be standing on E3
I guess the plus side this Blackfish one
B7 will be kind of dead for the next few
moves if the sensor locks up after D5
but you have to weigh up that move very
carefully so you're angling towards a
direct attack Judith maybe bringing the
Knight forward uh what else could wait
think about here
well that is something to think of but
I'm afraid that maybe after Knight H4 he
takes D4 and black will open up the
position though after Knight H4 the most
logical movies to go Bishop f8
especially that black played rookie 8
Bishop f8 is kind of the plan because
after Bishop f8 the B7 bishop and the E8
now
and everything on D4 and they put
pressure on the E4 Pawn
this could be a Target if things do open
up certainly uh it does worry me as well
for Ariane here that he's spent a lot of
time so far
um he's down 25 minutes on the clock
could be significant later on that tends
to be when things start to crumble for
him
but uh yeah for just a very tense very
balanced middle game so far should we
check in on the rest of the action
absolutely let's head back to the bird's
eye view
and shall we pay a visit to I mean other
games that I'd like to check in on as
the Wesley so good cash game
13 points in the tournament number three
here and also on the live rankings
number 13 in the world
opening up uh to see what number he
could climb to with a win he'll move up
to 12th in the world most likely go cash
yeah just such such a meteoric rise to
the top and he would Crown it off with a
nice result here he's been great in
Armageddon as well go cash so if he gets
that far if he holds the classical
opportunity well he had both against
Fabiano Fabiano could have been against
him in Armageddon but he could win
against Magnus
and what do we make of developments here
it hasn't changed too much apart from
the fact that Wesley has somehow
contorted his King and Rook so he's uh
King has landed back on its starting
square but at least he's activated these
two pieces pressure on D5
I quite like White's position I've got
to say even if uh
it doesn't look like anything too
special oh it looks very nice for a
white to be honest the Rooks on the one
and C1 optimally placed completely so
black will have to think
very much how to to look for counter
play maybe bishop F6 can be the move
because if
well Bishop E6 is also possible but
it feels passive it is the position is
passive that's why I'm thinking if you
Bishop F6 and I give away the D5 Pawn
but it's actually not a big threat to
take the D5 Pawn because then you can
play Bishop E6
and I spot that loose person on A2 yeah
both of these pawns potentially
vulnerable undefended on the queen side
yeah I'm liking both of those
suggestions uh or especially going for
the pawns immediately with Bishop to F6
Kakashi loves to calculate if he can he
loves to choose the active solution if
possible so I'm expecting something like
this bishop B6 would be like the last
resort to type a move if you calculate
and see nothing better then you just
curl up defend everything and hope your
position doesn't fall apart
well Bishop F6 seems to be the most
logical one yeah actually the future
church is pointing out that Wesley's
significantly lower on the clock he's
got half the time that go cash does
burning over an hour to get here Wesley
that's not too characteristic of him
usually he's quite quick quite practical
at the same time he can spend all his
time whatever how much he wants to
because it's the type of position you're
not in danger so if he has to Blitz five
minutes he's also not going to be losing
this game right or he can but it's it's
it then something very much has to go
wrong so it's a very stable position
where no complications really so then he
would just go simplification and draw
the game yeah for example later you can
put his Knight on D4 and just kind of
lock things down trade off everything
and it will fizzle out
so he's spending the time to try and
create something here cash finally for
the first time really in this game
uh Sinking Deep into thought yeah we're
expecting Bishop F6 but the game will be
decided a bit later
um how about how about Magnus should we
check in there I definitely have to
check in there because uh I for one
thought that this position was very
sophisticated and I wasn't sure how
white was going to just nurture a tiny
uh Advantage but
it looks like Magnus is doing his thing
again
yeah he's he's nursing those Bishops to
full health those white Bishops are
still alive as long as they live then
noddybeck is the one trying to equalize
but blacks Knights look active looks
like Black's got nice control in the
center Hikaru in his confessional we've
got to trust our fourth commentator he
said that nodu Beck was
um in preparation
and probably knew the details of this
kind of queenless middle game
do you think I mean I would take white
every time just because again minimal
risk just like Wesley he feels like
white can bail out uh
if necessary I also would take why
generally speaking because still I
believe that the white has a lot of
research in this position it's it's true
that black is very active with his
Knights and also the Rooks are on the
open file
but it's not clear what they can do
there so right in the later stage for
sure he's going to be playing B4 because
everything is preparing for that you
know that order to play B4 but for the
moment it's uh it's it's not a good move
I believe because of Knight E4 so The
Rook on F7 is not only standing on the
F5 but also defending the B7 which can
be uh very important because for example
now after b490 for ba5 Knight C3 the
pawn would be uh under attack otherwise
so white has to look for something where
uh important squares are E4 and D3 for
white so the question is how to control
those squares
but for now Knight D3 is not something
would bother why too much because he
would just play Bishop D2 or Bishop E3
to develop the bishop and move away so
white has to make some clever move maybe
rookie one
is a move I would consider for sure
rookie one right now yeah with that note
walk interrupt yeah oops
uh let's put this on the board
that was a bad one yeah I mean I'd love
to improve that piece too but Rook E1
may be met by Rook takes off too we have
to win 93 yeah sorry for the blonde
there no I mean I would make this
blunder myself definitely uh there's a
nasty Fork on the white king and Rook so
maybe white should be going uh instead
of rookie one what about Rook D1
B1 just to cover the knight from coming
into the D3 Square
though after this Knight G4 can be the
movement after F3 Knight E4
go into simplification yeah
big problems on F2 uh just to show that
Judah
suddenly black is in control
how to improve therefore I mean what
about going back to the good old
fashioned way of just pinning
the knights with Bishop F4
knowing Magnus he would want to as black
sacrifice The Rook for Bishop but yeah
like moves like nice sea yeah that's
what I would go
Knight C4 and if we simplify and we
exchange the bishop there then I think
black has a nice position yes outpost on
C4 E4 for tonight
yeah maybe the key is actually just to
make a small little improving move
instead of
um so this one this position looks great
for black as you both highlighted maybe
just to go
H3
just to stop at like getting to G4
yeah I like it there's no rush uh you
kind of play H3 eventually you hope to
carve out this nice safe Square for your
Bishop on E3 you might have to play B3
as well at some point but it takes a
while
I just I'm reminded of peterleko making
fun of me that I love to put my Bishops
on E1 so I'm looking at Bishop D2 if you
hit my Bishop I'm not sure how then I'll
just hide it so you can never capture it
but it feels too passive here I just
wanted to kind of provoke uh kind of
support F3 or B4 later but feels
artificial
either way this is the current position
Magnus needs an improving move and it's
not easy to find one actually
H3 but also I I can think of maybe B3 I
don't know B3 what happens Knight E4
but let's go H3 for the moment
okay
three
yeah how does black improve that's the
kind of inverse question here because
then next move I can go Rook D1 if I
wanted too much
uh if I want it very much to to be
played it's good to take away the square
the G4 Square from the Knight
let's improve The Rook
let's say our weight is black let's say
I just pass G6 I want to take away the
F5 Square from your knight yeah let's
say Rook D1
I don't want to see your knight on D3
yeah
so tense and also don't forget that
maybe I don't play Rook D1 but I play
Bishop H6
because finally I have a nice Square
there I gave you a square the last thing
I needed to give your Bishop a beautiful
square a nice home and now H3 is the
most relevant move on the board you
Banker you've prevented Knight G4 nice
one
I think yeah I mean imagine Magnus
playing it uh I think he might do it's a
Magnus type of move as well H3 right
just uh kind of preventative
yeah it's a good wait and see move and
as you highlighted it's also difficult
for black to improve four it's the other
move you mentioned yeah but this one was
awarded a question mark by the panel
because of Knight C4 oh
have to find out black snipe is likely
to come to C4 and a dark squared Bishop
trade will favor Black getting rid of
the bishoper
hey I'm surprised as well gotta say
unless he's got some tricks up his
sleeve what happens if after Knight C4
wide goes B3 yeah Bishop F4 B takes C4
let's jump into this just before we head
back to the Hikaru Nakamura against
Fabiana caruana game well Hikaru uh game
is Fabiano he's still thinking still
thinking he's simply I mean he has to
think it's yeah but critical moment
imagine how much confidence your car is
gaining by the fact that Fabiano has
gone into the tank now for so long but
uh we'll get to that point soon uh Judy
you mentioned B3 and Counter-Strike now
Bishop takes Bishop is met by Pawn takes
Knight
and suddenly black has to move this
piece Bishop D2
let's I assume continue I thought the C
takes the five
and now with Bishop C3 I believe Knight
E6 can be unpleasant nice tactics nice
geometry here if black takes the knights
off the board Rook takes poor now is
impossible due to a nasty pin all the
targets on light squares
lined up nicely
yeah yeah this is not possible
this is the type of thing Magnus will
calculate as well I know him too well
he's hoping for Knight to C4 and B3
and if we go back go back again B3
Bishop F4 B take C4 sorry this position
Bishop D2
C takes D5 and if black takes back and I
thought that it would be five maybe to
move
the night hitting the pawn behind it and
one day when Bishop comes to B3 that
will hurt but there are some tricks like
Bishop takes C3 and then I thought Rook
takes C5 Bishop takes D4 Rook D5 yeah
and after that some Bishop B3 unpleasant
things
yes
certainly unpleasant and very well
calculated by Magnus and meanwhile our
fourth commentator Hikaru Nakamura just
keeps pumping out the content we have
another video of him in the confessional
so let's take it to Hikaru who breaks
down his current position
yeah so I saw Magnus was just in here
and that kind of made me want to come
back and I mean as Fabian was using more
and more time and becoming more and more
optimistic about my position I think the
main reason I'm so optimistic is because
in this position since I'm up two pawns
Fabiano basically has to have counter
play right away if he doesn't have
counter play right away I can say play
B4 B5 and undermine the Central Pawn on
E5 his position is going to fall apart
almost instantly and so in this
situation it's really really good
because from the general standpoint of
needing being in a must-win game Fabiano
doesn't have any easy moves and if he
has something really good I'm sure he'll
find it but realistically If he if he
doesn't find it all my moves are going
to be extremely easy to play I think so
I'm actually feeling more and more
optimistic and and the longer Fabiano
thinks the more confident I've become
now of course who knows what the
objective evaluation is but the fact
that Fabiano played F5 and now he's deep
in the tank I'm not sure what the
difference is but I know there's some
positions where you're not supposed to
play Knight E4 after c5s after Bishop f8
Bishop A3 there is F5 but I think
because of this Rook C one move being
here it's completely different than the
line that Fabian was trying to transpose
to and I think Fabiano probably actually
realizes this which is why which is why
he's thinking so long here so the longer
Fabiano thinks the more confident I
become and I'm feeling really really
good about this game right now now of
course maybe I'm being too too
optimistic of course I'm sure he has
some resource and Fabian was an
extremely good calculator
um but the laundry things the closer we
get towards event an eventual time
scramble I I just I become very uh very
optimistic so I'm very pleased with
everything I've gotten and I could not
have asked for more so far and we'll see
what happens
and uh there we saw Hikaru saying he
feels he's feeling really really good
about the position
and saying giving us an Insight that he
thinks Fabiana carono just got his move
orders mixed up
well probably this is the case and it
was also important to see which is a
very typical
uh case when your opponent is thinking
long you gain self-confidence on the
other side because if your opponent is
not making a move quickly it means that
he miscalculated something or mis
evaluated something so it means that
he's in trouble and then you're like
you're you're self-confident grows but
of course at the end you have to make
the right move and queen D5 was played
which is probably the only move to
continue the game uh pretending that
black has enough compensation for the
pawn right because somehow black has to
get activity without activity he just
has the two pawns down yeah I've got to
say with the two of you surprised by the
fact that Hikaru I mean he seemed
confident he said he was happy but I
mean the fact that he wasn't jumping up
and down if it were me I'd be you know I
wouldn't be able to contain my
excitement here just a beautiful
position for white extra material
everything going his way
yeah but they say you know especially
when you play chess that it's good to
have a little bit of everything you know
you can't have too much happiness
because this will lead to over
excitement and then you make rash
decisions on the board so a tiny bit of
happiness is good but you can leave the
celebrations for when the game is
finished
absolutely and and you could see that he
was like really happy about his position
he's happy he's he's very he couldn't
get a better position out of the opening
but I also felt that he just cannot
believe it that this is what he has
after move 15 in a must win situation
do you think he knows I mean he knows he
has the advantage do you think he knows
it's winning if he's uh accurate here
huge huge uh this is interesting that I
think he does not know that he's winning
he feels that it's a good position but
also the confirmation came from Fabi
spending so much time
but if he would know that the game is
winning
then it would be a much better situation
for him and for the moment he knows it
well it should be pretty good I mean I
feel good about it I don't see enough
compensation but I think he must think
that well I'm a little bit better but I
have to play well and by far he is not
necessarily thinking that he has a huge
Advantage which kind of brings me on to
a question when you guys assess
positions do you ever have that absolute
assessment I'm winning because
having spoken to a lot of people they
just say oh well I'm going to improve my
Bishop oh well I'm going to improve this
port and only when they know it's a
hundred percent in the bank do they go
I'm winning
well it depends on the position right
right I mean yeah in this position you
don't say that I'm winning and even if
you see the computer saying that it's
plus four you say well okay it's plus
four but you have to win it right
exactly so it's it can be kind of tricky
because the players know it by now that
even if the engine says something very
huge advantage in practice it can it can
be very misleading that how to really
convert your advantage your objective
Advantage into Victory that's a whole
completely there are different story
yeah
yeah so back to the game we uh as
mentioned there ivanko we saw uh Fabiano
pause for 30 odd minutes I think 32 33
minutes on that last move as black
eventually Queen D5 was the product of
that deep think and uh true that you
mentioned it was one of the only moves
to keep black in the game how is Hikaru
going to react we were discussing what's
Queen coming to C2 just to try and trade
off the Queens uh is that still the most
logical move in your mind
well it is logical at the same time What
uh Nakamura also said that B4 B5 is kind
of an idea what he wants to play and
queen C2 is on the board because the APO
A2 Pawn would be taken by
you
maybe not by Fabby but your Banker would
have gobbled up that pawn if B4 had
happened I hold my hands off and say yes
so okay protecting A2 just in case you
want to push the B Pawn forward but uh
also more pertinently Queen C4
wow how to stop that is it a threat
first of all and Nakamura I think he's
just so enthusiastic that he cannot sit
in the chair right now because he just
cannot believe it that he thinks he's
winning but he cannot believe it that
he's winning
is Hikaru a Pacer by Nature I've seen
him at multiple kind of tournaments
where he's he's a vote of a mix if he's
confident or if he's bored as he's said
in the confessional then often he does
Pace but it's a bit of a mixture he
loves to stay focused and
I mean this is before the pandemic that
I kind of saw him a bit more over the
board he doesn't play so much uh OTB
recently but yeah it's kind of a mix a
lot of players that defined either by
pacing or by sitting historically at the
board he's I would say in the middle
somewhere but this game well now I think
he's not pacing he's just attached to
the confessional Booth part four episode
four coming soon I think half of the
time at least when he stands up from his
chair he's going to the confessional
Booth right
okay and how annoying is it for Fabiano
because he probably knows that's exactly
what Fabi that sorry Hikaru is doing so
he's suffering he's made a blunder and
then you know that every every long
thing that you do he's gonna be there
this is the last thing you have in mind
when you are having troubles on the
board
yeah I think the fact that he knows his
position is quite bad by now it's
focusing his mind Fabiano uh so while he
focuses on finding defensive resources
should we try and uh find the best for
him what's going to be the less evil in
this position yeah let's see how
Glenn tried to save it
and look for counter plays of course
black has to
avoid by any means to exchange the
Queens because if it's going to be
exchanged then it's uh
it's an even a verse version of it
I believe but I don't see exactly how he
can avoid that that's the only problem
if King h8 then anyway quick Queen C4
yeah
no way to avoid this trade unless you go
all the way back home but that surely uh
won't work yeah but I think after going
home to d8 it means Queen's Queen F7 for
example
white breaks oh there's many moves I
mean white can also play uh B4 B5 or
Carter mentioned that himself
just yeah it should be too maybe that's
the easiest just Bishop B2 and go to the
diagonal and it's not only that white
has two extra pawns but white has the
activity also so it's just over
yeah this one is resignable so maybe the
conclusion there is that we cannot avoid
the trade of queens and if we cannot
avoid that which is a very bad news yeah
or black that's for sure
it's all about this bishop if you could
just teleport it anywhere else if you
could put it on F7 uh if you could put
it on H5 somewhere then you'd be okay
but this bishop is totally caged by the
White Knight and definitely cannot take
the White Knight off because the queen
replaces it and as you said Julie
earlier this Pawn drops this time it's
the same thing we showed but even worse
for black because Queens have been
eliminated three-point deficit too much
wow what else well it must be so
frustrating to see this position from
the black side
that he just uh I mean this this is when
you're just cursing yourself that how
could I do this
right would I end up in this position
and move 16 you know
yes without having a game right because
out of the opening it was one two moves
and it's uh collapsing
yeah it's a heartbreaking error from
Fabi but you know he still has to keep
the game alive you know the principle of
uh increased resistance as ding was
saying in his world championship match
okay if there's no immediate win then
just look at the line that's going to
prolong things so I'm just thinking
maybe you go Bishop E6 and just stay
you know the the there's a Pawn on D3
that if you manage to reinforce your
position you can use that one as a
Target
yeah Bishop E6 is something very
sensible but for example uh first of all
anyway I can go Queen C4
or just
taking on E6
let's take on E6 so so my idea after
taking on E6 was obviously to capture
back with the Rook otherwise all manner
of material falls and you don't want
that and then okay let's say it captures
the bishop I'm not sure it's the best
maybe but okay Rook takes and queen C4
yeah
and then the idea was basically just to
say okay the trade is going to happen
but I will try to make sure that you if
you want the Queens off the board you
capture me so Rook d8
and yeah for example if the Rooks if the
Queens disappear right now Ivanka then
maybe this is holdable for black or at
least it's something something yeah
everything is covered at least and as
you mentioned this point is a target but
to me it looks like a miserable defense
ahead white just brings The Rook up and
still two Pawn uh Advantage looks very
very strong for Hikaru yeah maybe that's
even better than this
Queen C2 on the board yes uh difficult
decision for Fabiano Carona but in the
meantime our reporter svera caught up
with Chris Littlejohn who is hikaru's
second to ask him his thoughts on the
position and also to talk about the role
of being a second at a tournament
and and Chris I thought it was funny
Hikaru he was uh really really throwing
it out there he was saying either
Fabiano has messed up or my second is
overlooked something drastically what
was the correct answer here uh the
correct answer it looks like is that
Fabiano messed up so I think Fabiano
confused the lines
um instead of Bishop A3 there's a
possibility to play 94 first and in this
line uh what Fabiano did with F5 can
occur but with what we have on the board
with Rook C1 and Knight C6 included what
Fabiano did just doesn't work at all and
it seems very very promising for your
cover right now
and there we heard Chris littlejohn's
um Hikaru is long time second we had
there for over 15 years telling us that
yeah Fabiano had made an error had mixed
things up
and they're in chat fried liver
officially a grand master opening I mean
it's always been a grand master opening
despite his funny name
yeah it hasn't been in fashion for a
while with whites but yeah I think it's
normally employed by uh maybe less
experienced players who just want to go
directly for the kill or more
experienced players trying to outplay
younger rivals in these totally wild uh
type of positions that ensue and
meanwhile we have a move Rook to d8 on
the board
what do we think of this absolutely Rook
date is uh on the board so black wants
to put pressure on the D3 bone by any
means I'm thinking what about Queen C
Serena because I want to put pressure on
the E5 Pawn
blacks move the consequences it does
weaken the E5 Pawn yes I mean
immediately pinpointing the weakness of
the move possibly after a rook moved
from E8 to d8
because if let's say queen C4 that's the
most logical right if Queen C4 then
uh
what Fabiano could have thought of is to
take on C5
let's jump in and show this Fabian is
just left away from the bud
so Queen C4 is maybe the most obvious
move or the most consistent move at
least and here you mentioned after
Quincy 4 Judith Bishop takes C5 Bishop
take C5 and another question is how
white is continuing because let's say
queen takes D5
Rook D5 Rook take C5
yeah I guess I have to take you
thanks thanks
yeah how to defend the spawn looks
hopeless this end game well you can
counter attack
Bishop A6
I'm I'm spotting those weak horns but uh
it's like not enough really well the
question is let's see if rookie ate ah
sorry after not tc5
the problem is there are really a lot of
Pawns missing from Black's position yeah
let's just show that line once again uh
it was
this position
and Hikaru is very much on the edge of
playing it yeah rookie eight I guess
just D4 here and
yeah I think he's gonna place
this queen C4 move get the Queens off
the board as you mentioned Jude at this
type of position too it's very hard to
resist to play not to play Queen C4
right even if something else is better
Queen C4 is a move that you know that
you exchange the Queens it's one way
it's for two results
yeah the other move you mentioned Queen
C3 also looks good just attacking the
spawn but slightly more tension left
on the board
so it's just about whether he goes for
it now or finesses it with
a kind of stepping stone move first
but actually after Queen C4 Bishop
Bishop C5 also possible just to capture
it back first on C5 not to exchange the
Queens first because the queen cannot
Escape From The Exchange I thought to
the bishop aha yeah maybe the queen is
better though
or maybe after Queen C5 after Queen C5 I
would go Bishop B7 yeah and I can be
happy for a moment
some tricks along the diagonal well it's
not even much of a trick but at least if
uh black white cannot take on E5 there
is a trick because Knight takes E5 and
there's problem on G2 oops Yeah that
would be a blonde there takes on D5 and
then Rook takes but obviously this not
this is not going to be missed
by white so after Bishop B7 is at least
I feel that I have little compensation
after that
so let's have a
Queen C4 let's have a vote at least it's
gonna happen let me see four
yeah you it's too tempting right but I
do really like your queen C3 but yeah
Queen C4
yeah I I originally thought B4 but
sometimes this bishop is kind of caught
offside for a move or two uh but yeah
I'll vote Quincy for as well looks like
we're all assuming Hikaru is simply
going to take the Queens off but it's
interesting he wanted already to play
this move he had the hand the movement
that he wants to play but now his uh his
head is in his hands and it seems like
no I go back to think and decide the
best
yeah and that's actually a good strategy
right you don't let your impulses take
over and you're just okay let me be
objective about the position do what
needs to be done
he does have a motion of time right now
uh Hikaru still over one hour 20 we've
already reached move 20 so halfway to
the point before the players get
incremented and yeah I think he's well
within his rights to pause and it's nice
to have that self-control uh to have
that alertness you don't want to rush
too much with excitement that's how
points can slip away
for any moment now we are expecting
Fabiano
well this can be a problem for uh for
Nakamura that he of course he he can get
over excited that for a chance and this
is my chance and what happens if I'm
winning so obviously it's very hard to
eliminate this thought while having a
very good advantage in the position
secondly when you have a very good
position or winning position almost you
always have several Alternatives and and
for that you have to be very strong
because the amount of grand Masters I
met who were complaining that I was
winning but
[Laughter]
there is a lot of saying that you
experienced it it's always an excuse
right yeah it's better to sit there and
focus and recalculate especially when
you have such a Time Advantage also and
really think about it Queen C4 Queen C3
Bishop B2 I mean there are several
Alternatives and also that maybe if
Quince it's not a matter of whether
white is better or not the question is
whether Queen C4 is the best because the
one thing what black can be playing for
is somehow simplify the position to a
different color uh opposite color Bishop
end game with the Rooks or moreover
without the Rooks and then maybe two
extra pawns will not be enough so this
is somehow where things can go wrong for
white
yeah
absolutely and on that note I think it's
the perfect time to take a small break
and first of all we mentioned though the
junior speed Chess Championship which is
just days away from the Speedy Junior
speeches Championship where the
strongest young talent in speed chess
will go head to head for their share of
fifty thousand dollars but they aren't
the only ones with a shot to win big
fill out and submit your jscc bracket
for a chance to win six months of
premiership.com membership submission
closes when the first match begins so
don't miss your chance use x-clam
fantasy in chat to submit your bracket
and we'll be back with a final round of
noise chess right after this break
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki and
Josh Toth everyone's favorite social
media troll known as Anish Geary and so
many more chessable can help you raise
your game to the next level you're
getting started on the fundamentals you
should check out everyone's first chess
workbook
maybe you want to stop letting all those
points slip away in the end game 100 end
games you must know is the course for
you
did you not notice your king was in
check and still can't figure out why the
pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kit is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
fifty thousand chest bustles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ing alongside the absolutely wonderful
Grandmasters Judith Polgar and David
Howell and well we've seen a lot of
excitement already
and the biggest news was actually
Fabiana Carona blundering and making a
very heartbreaking error actually to
it feels like almost
spoil the game completely
has there been any action should we
let's check out the bird's eye view and
see what's happened yeah uh the only
action is that Queens are indeed off the
board we predicted this before the break
uh as mentioned as well Hikaru Nakamura
two pawns up close to glory in the
tournament and just during the break I
was thinking about it actually Fabiano
maybe he knew too much about this
opening he knew that F5 was an idea just
like Hikaru second was saying but he
couldn't remember the move order and in
these cases it's better to know nothing
at all it's better to kind of rely on
your own calculation it feels like he
was trying to make this move work when
it didn't and uh it's all backfired
especially in such an opening where
things do matter one Tempe here one
Tempe there and the big difference is
that the Rook was standing already on C1
so every piece of white was ready to
meet this F5 move with a good reaction
taking capturing the pawn and after that
immediately Queen C2 Queen C4 was coming
and black was not able to stop this
because Black's position was not active
at all having his Bishops on C8 and f8
and the queen back on d8 and E8 The
Rook at the time and after F5 it is it
was a two active move as we say
sometimes because there are a lot of
weaknesses what
has happened to Black on the King on G8
got vulnerable with all those Knight G5
opportunities also so yeah this one
mistake can cost him the whole game and
the tournaments exactly because these
two are battling it out for first place
Hikaru Laura is in a must-win situation
he needs to get a classical win to take
those 33 points three points not 33
points
and LeapFrog over Fabiana caruana and
that brings us to the Crux of the matter
is it enough now will Hikaru get nervous
it's been going a bit too well for him
uh he will not have expected this Beyond
his Wildest Dreams to be two pawns up uh
especially half an hour up and swell on
the clock after a couple of hours of
play is there any chance of him going
wrong here how does white improve how
does white guarantee that he can convert
this material lead
is a big question how white is going to
be converting his Advantage his extra
two points into Victory because there is
a pin with the Knight on C5 so the f8
bishop is standing on its initial square
but at the same time it is active piece
so the question is how white wants to be
realizing the advantage for example can
white go away with the Knight to A4
which we've seen this kind of idea
before giving up the bishop and then
black is able to to play with two
Bishops I think that's that's not the
first move which Wright wants to be
considering for example Rook from E1 to
C1 it's something to consider seriously
I believe because after Rook C1 defend
the inputting doubling The Rook
defending the C5 Knight which makes it
possible in the next move to go Bishop
from A3 out of the PIN to go back to B2
and the question is how black will be
placing his Bishop from C8 because it
seems so that for that you have to
eliminate the C5 Knight first
right
is it also an idea to make moves like
so so hang on let me just is black ever
threatening to go F4
or is that just in order to bring the
bishop yeah
well I think that's one of the idea if
you don't want to capture on C5 and
bring your Bishop out then basically
that's the only idea to play BF4 and
with the idea Bishop G4 attacking the
Knight or Bishop F5
right so that's why I was actually
thinking that maybe G3 might be a move
although it looks ugly because I am
weakening the light squares
G3 just preventing black or at least uh
deterring Black from playing the move F4
makes a lot of sense
um I mean Hikaru here he'll be looking
at the forcing moves or the more direct
moves so I think maybe yours do that B4
here does protect the Knight break the
pin but it doesn't feel uh kind of too
intuitive to blocking your Bishop on A3
right now I'm just saying this because
he mentioned it in the confessional that
idea a bit earlier Hikaru so maybe still
on his radar
I think we are going to reach out in in
the next four or five moves something
that we simplify to one rook and Bishop
versus a rook bishop and white has these
double pawns on the default so black is
trying to get gone to play and uh try to
save the game with the different color
Bishop ideas
should we try and illustrate that on the
board
let's jump in and show a possible a
plausible variation here
um
first yeah let's back up that night
support the Knight on C5
and now my plan is to go Bishop B2 so
black has to decide
for for some reason this and the side of
the bar it doesn't doesn't like my move
Rock C1 the most logical move it's
changing it's fine maybe because I was
complaining it just went up a little bit
it hurt you
the engine stockfish heard you there
Judith and okay meanwhile I don't even
see a logical move let's say I play a
move like A5 I just let's say A5 can I
go back with the Bishop from A3 to B2 I
wanted to give my knight a potential
launch pad maybe before but then I
dropped this Pawn on E5
yes but maybe it's not enough for me
because after night before and if I take
Knight E5 Knight A2 and I I have to
leave the C line with my rook and then
it's a chasing you will chase my Rook
with Rook C2 Knight B4 yeah otherwise
this white knight will drop off if the
white Rook moves away
um okay one here I guess yeah but
they're already black has some way of
fighting for a draw right Bishop Rook
take C5 and after rookie to Rook A2
Bishop E6 yeah forcing white to exchange
on C5 so this is this is the best
position
blackhead up to this point since he
played F5 in the opening yeah some
drawing chances here still difficult
but yeah Rook ec1 looks like the way
let's say I play that A5 move again is
there anything cleaner there is a
comment in chat saying D4 is resigned
now
is that really true wow okay let's go
back to the game position so instead of
Rook e to C1 but after D4 E4 was my
problem
oh D4 does not look like resign now
unless you mean for your coverage and
chances of winning the tournament
because yeah this is ugly to allow uh
this kind of step forward kicking away
the White Knight suddenly once the White
Knight moves this D4 Pawn will drop as
well and momentum turns
um maybe it was D4 in a different
position yeah but yeah still a logical
move uh White would love to break
forward but unfortunately now this can
be bypassed with E4
so always looking for born breaks is the
right way to do things Hikaru will do
that for the rest of the game just uh in
this specific position I would also like
to ask you something can I go Bishop B2
here
wow so Bishop B2
I'm trying to work out how to trick you
back
the ship takes nights
one night B4
is isn't there um Rook takes first and
then then you go Bishop D4
ah nice spot you hacker all done yeah
Bishop D4 I think that would have taken
me uh well I probably would have blunted
into this is why this
counter-attacking idea loose piece
it's not so simple for Nakamura because
you feel that you have a huge Advantage
but uh
it can happen that well this is not
enough and then you calculate the other
line it's not good enough I should have
more in this position right
just to I mean you wouldn't be happy to
have only one phone up yeah this is
where you get itchy fingers you kind of
want to rush the wind you play Move Like
D4 or B4 and you regret later yeah so
rookie C1 is one of the idea if B4 I
don't like B4 for some reason yeah
as uh said in the future chat it is easy
to mess it up actually we shouldn't
forget the Practical side there's of
course external factors the psychology
here
um I think most mere models would mess
this up but Hikaru is Hikaru and he's
been given a head start a handicap here
so B4 yeah maybe just A6 just to stop
the white B form moving forward well
also it'll be it is possible after
before
oh that's even more effective yeah
the white Bishop doesn't really want to
be stuck on the side of the board for
too much longer
what do we think is he going to find a
convincing move here
so let's say Knight A4 let's see why
this is not so good okay I don't like to
give up my Bishop on A3 but let's see
jump in to show this Knight to A4
ships versus Knights that's the question
you know which side I'm picking now dude
suddenly even two pawns down
well actually maybe not I try to defend
their phones yeah this is the key Pawn
here
hmm I wanted to drop back originally
just to hold everything together but
it feels a bit shaky uh after this
[Music]
I thought Knight C3 is very strong yep
forcing me to take your pawn and then I
take on E5 yeah
and unfortunately I've taken an ugly
Pawn on D3 you've taken a very important
Pawn on E5
um yeah unfortunately Rick takes Pawn
walks into Knight C4 yeah and that's
losing
double attack
Knights are tricky
yeah it is a good uh simplifying move
but psychologically I don't think I
could bring myself to
just get a position where there's two
Bishops against two knights
yeah I'm on your team here I literally
wouldn't even consider Knight A4 that
beautiful Bishop pair for black but
still two pawns or two Pawns and it's a
pin right so
don't break the chain don't break the
pin yeah I think he can break the pin by
stepping back with the Knight
so after rookie C1 you go A5 right
or what was it I was trying A5 uh just
like it was A5
A5 and the bishop couldn't come to B2
because of Knight B4 idea
so that made a lot of sense
long think from Hikaru here nearly 15
minutes okay
so obviously he's not finding it easy
actually to come up with a way to make
things simple for him to enjoy those
extra two pawns and in the meantime
should we go and look at the bird's eye
view and have a wander at the other
games just one question I have
okay what was the question I heard
Knight E6
oh
maybe we'll go back and investigate that
one uh once the curry maybe plays it
well let's go in now again it's some
crazy idea but I just had an idea that
after 96 you cannot take the bishop on
A3 because Knight C7
wow
those tricky notes I've said it before
those pesky nights that's a nasty Fork
you can't defend both trucks at the same
time and white comes up with uh an extra
at least two pawns again simplified
version this time and if I take your
knight instead
then my plan was to go Rook the xc6 and
yeah
I want to save this bishop somehow if I
drop back and in Bishop D7 I thought to
go Rook A6
okay I understand that on A3 my Rook
would not be standing so beautifully I
appreciate yes uh Bishop C8 and chasing
my Rook yeah you have to keep defending
this bishop and if you step back okay
four Bishop D7 that's nice Eternal
harassment uh this Rook kind of find a
safe Square otherwise yeah you're
simplifying favorably but tactics here
okay that's a nice spot though I've got
to say 96.
tactical Vision he covers perfectly
calculated that as well he's going to be
spending at least a decent portion of
his time oh and he's made a move he's
gone for our first suggestion of this
logical doubling the Rooks on the C line
and uh off he goes and uh leaves Fabiano
caruana to ponder so let's revisit the
bird's eye view and have a quick Roundup
of the situation on the other boards
so for the standings it was super
important to
the game between Wesley so and good cash
last time we left it we thought it was
very nice for Wesley so
is it still nice
it's still nice from a perspective that
Wesley so will not lose this game but I
don't think he's going to win this game
either good cash has just played an
extremely nice uh strong move there we
see Wesley on the camera
someone's standing in front uh kind of
watching his game now but Wesley had in
hands realizing that his chances of
winning this classical game have
disappeared because gokesh has simply
traded off all the pieces it's opposite
color Bishops yes Rooks remain but this
last Pawn push really nice opening up
this black Bishop so the isolated form
will be traded for a very healthy pawn
and no issues I'll get an incoming but
which is important to notice that after
Rook D4 black cannot take the G2 Pawn
immediately because of Rook G4 but after
Rook D4 I believe the easiest way for
black to equalize is to play rookie 8
attacking the E5 Bishop first and only
after that whatever White's reaction is
if they move he moves away the bishop
only then it will be captured on G2 uh
important detail there uh Judith yeah
and go cash for sure has foreseen this
at the same time Bishop D4 is possible
so after Bishop G2 Bishop A7 but Rick
comes to attack the bishop and the
um okay done yes
let's put a couple of these variations
on the board and then I think we can
leave this one uh as the players Rush
towards that draw and towards the arm
again yes Ivanka uh default really nice
classy move there from kukesh just
showing such great maturity and as
Judith mentioned first of all Rook takes
D4 uh Bishop takes G2 is not advisable
due to Rook G4 with a double attack
hitting G two heading G7 this is uh at
least going to be an extra Pawn for
white in the end game uh instead of Rook
to E8 hitting the bishop and no way for
white to keep the balance or at least
keep the uh formation that he wanted if
the bishop does move then safety Bishop
takes G2 and level material and uh as
your Banker pointed out as well a
similar line of an equally important
Bishop takes porn Bishop takes porn and
now taking this one is met nice and
simply by Rook to A8 with a skewer at
the very end this A2 Pawn drops and
again total balance
it's gonna be a draw yep definitely and
uh well let's head back to the bird's
eye view and see if there are any other
armageddon's
incoming Let's uh let's have a look at
uh
which one should we go to should we go
to Magnus Carlson nordebec
I would like to see Anish also for a
short time let's go there then because
there is some very beautiful
position form on each perspective
yeah and Anish versus uh Shakira here
also opposite color Bishops but this
time with Queens added to the equation
another set of Rooks added as a bit of
extra flavor and compared the Bishops
this time relative to the game between
Wesley so and go cash this time it's
clear which Bishop is dominant and yes
opposite color Bishops but that does not
mean that this game is drawish it means
actually that white has established a
bind on the dark squares
are you surprised you to see the
evaluation bar in the center here level
material it looks like this bishop far
superior to its counterpart well it
looks amazingly beautiful with the white
side and the important part is for why
that after Rook E6 white is going to be
defending the bishop like by playing
Rook D1 so probably black will have to
sacrifice a pawn by playing C5 to be
able to eliminate the Bishop from D6 but
then white is going to have a pawn up
and is going to bring it to D4
centralize it so it could be a very
difficult game for black
yeah despite the evaluation bar saying
that this is roughly balanced it feels
like now is the critical moment for
mamaturif if he finds nothing then he's
simply going to be paralyzed I mean this
black Rook is going to be rendered
offside soon this black Bishop may never
move if he doesn't find a way out over
the next few turns yeah
C4 and C5 will just cement that Bishop
on D6 so yeah I completely agree
Shaq does need to break out
get that light squared Bishop cracking
and okay let's go back to the bird's eye
view and pop in on I think should we go
to our antari alireza because
there appears to be a lot of fireworks
there
but maybe not fireworks that's a bit of
a strong move but you know there's a
knight on the F4 Square
Storm is Coming yes in that game but
isn't there some action time for black
like Knight G2 kind of move oh wow
Judith tactics on the board we do see
that uh White's last move given a red
cross that means a miss that was
something better in the position for
white maybe something a bit stronger and
has this allowed some tricks black could
take this Pawn this uh is based on the
fact that after a trade of dark Square
Bishops Black's Queen will jump out to
G5 a bit later on there we see the
definition of uh these little Graphics
uh yeah it's a myth didn't find the key
move and will he be punished ariant
hurry I don't know because at first of
course it comes to mind what about
Knight G2 let's jump in yeah
Boom the top players always look for
these forcing moves first
and let's say I take your knight and
then if you take the Knight Bishop takes
E3 Rook takes E3
Queen G5 check
Knight G4 only move to protect the Rook
H5
and then I believe the only move for
white is to play H4
and after this uh going to F4 Maybe
yeah Queen F4 just to keep this right
that's my first intention attacked and
uh and black seems to be having a great
position
yeah this looks fantastic the Knight
will be captured next move and white
White's King just too vulnerable you
regain the material with interest yeah
and if you play Queen E2 then H takes G4
tanks and Knight comes to F6 attacking
the opponent G4 and also sometimes to
think about Knight D5 sacrifices
forget yeah don't forget that sleeping
Bishop that Sleeping Giant on the
diagonal so after Knight G2 I don't know
what exactly
can be a saving opportunity for why
there's also an idea after not g to play
Bishop G5 and after Queen G5 Knight H3
which after I thought to go Knight E3
Knight G5 Knight D1
I don't know if I'm blundering something
probably Knight F7 is the move but even
this position black I mean even if I
kind of be lazy here and just take this
Knight back surely this is a good
transition Black's Knight can come
around to F4
yes Black's Bishop will find New Life
breath of fresh air on the C8 Square
feels like Superior minor pieces for
black Superior Pawn structure this is a
backward Pawn might not be much but
uh just depends whether this is forced
or whether fruja has something better in
the current position Knight takes G2
woof
well this is an option for sure for
black the only thing the question is
whether alireza will find it enough or
he wants to go
somewhere further and play a longer game
it's very tempting right you
wreck the white Pawn structure you give
yourself permanent access to the F4
square and the calculations work out in
your favor it's enough right
it is enough unless your name is alireza
and you're the most ambitious player in
chess and you want to keep tension every
time he gets given an option he'll go
for the one that kind of is most
unpleasant for the opponent and maybe
he'll he'll have one eye on aryan's
clock under uh well around 36 minutes
now maybe he'll just want to keep asking
questions rather than head down a long
long forcing line where we'll kind of
have a lot of moves quickly and maybe a
level-ish engage and uh by the way the
game between Wesley sir and gukesh will
100 and in a draw and we will be seeing
our first final round Armageddon
yeah oh just as I speak it finishes in a
drawer so in 20 minutes those two
players will be facing off with uh oh
well faster and more Furious time
controls
yeah and uh just before we see that uh
Armageddon
okay we see some confusion some
discussion here between the two players
they're talking to the Arbiter right now
maybe just asking when the Armageddon
starts
kakash has left the black king in the
center but normally that means black is
one this game was a draw
a bit naughty there he should retract
his king or Wesley should have left his
King in the center as well but
either way good classical tournament for
good cash absolutely amazing classical
tournament for him you know to be third
in the standings with the world's best
players in the lineup is just incredible
so fantastic future for the 17 year old
good cash and now he will face off in
his final Armageddon and he's also been
Armageddon King he's won four out of
five
impressive yeah will he make it five out
of six good cash
yeah yesterday was one of the games of
the tournament and he'll want to finish
this experience off here in Stavanger on
a high
okay
can we go and look at magnus's game for
short
and then we can go back to hikaru's game
because there were some moves also over
there
see if Magnus can end this tournament
with a win with a classical Victory it
looks like a set of Rooks are off the
board I believe it it favors white what
happened in the last six seven moves
or even less white played F3 improved
his King to F2 he played B3 covering all
the possible
squares where the Knight could have
jumped to C4 E4 G4 everything is covered
E3
and of course it's not easy to say how
is it going to be progressing in this
game but still with the bishop pair I
believe that one day B4 will arrive on
the board yeah maybe after H3 and G and
F4
only after that
I mean does white have ideas of actually
going Bishop A3
and then at the right time F4 you know
the Knight on D5 can start looking at
the C6 Pawn
it feels that there's plenty of room to
kind of soften Black's position up I'm
wondering actually is is there some uh
trick opportunity for white to go Bishop
A3 and after Bishop D6
put this on the board no there are no
tricks oh three is touching nonetheless
because I was thinking about after
Bishop D6 if the king would be on G2
maybe Knight B5 could be an option but
that that would be bad for other reasons
but Avanti Knight B5 takes Rook D5 but
then Knight D3
is here but black jumps out the way
trades everything off and whoops at the
very end the white Bishop is loose so it
doesn't quite work out but close and
definitely the type of thing on magnus's
radar maybe white can set it up with an
improving move
what type of improving move move the
king F1 yes because we cannot go to G2
because then there is a night jump and
rookie too sometimes that gives the hard
time
but Bishop E3 is a move which uh seems
to be a nice one
indirectly hitting a loose piece an
undefended night there so Knight C6 is a
threat
but he played H4 yeah it's Magnus I can
tell you that I would bet on a Magnus
winning this game what do you think
if it was any other tournament I would
100 bet on Magnus winning this game but
things have gone against him annoy
chassis
lack the Killer Instinct to finish games
off he's been slightly unlucky in some
games
do you think
I really do feel that Magnus always
makes a comeback so I I think it will be
a point of principle to him that he will
not finish this tournament in a with a
negative score so it's all systems go
and he will try it out this is this his
type of position right he has extra time
on the clock and he will like to improve
slowly but slowly actually I think he's
just clearly better yeah yeah actually
after I saw the opening I thought okay
this is beautiful for whites like
computer might have said 0.0 but this is
a Magnus type of position
it's old Manchester as he calls it
himself just don't give the youngsters
any tactics uh any calculation and it's
interesting to see the top players kind
of go back to basics uh in such critical
games Hikaru did that he said he pulled
out an idea from 2009 and he's rehashing
it and reusing it here in such an
important game and Magnus things have
gone wrong for him but now he's going
back to his roots of uh just grinding
out small advantages taking small
positional edges and
um yeah just keeping things simple
well it will be not an easy game but I
think slowly but surely he will be able
to convert his small advantage
these Bishops will come to life most
likely at some point H4 does hint at H5
creating some squares for the White
Knight to use
well and the the both I mean C1 Bishop
is really powerful looking to go to A3
time to time but also thinking about
going Bishop G5 or Bishop H6 or Bishop
F4 so interestingly enough it's uh it's
standing the best on C1 probably in this
position keeping the Alternatives and
the options for which game which way it
is going to be moving away
yeah likewise the light squared Bishop
defends the queen side and has some eyes
on the other flank as well very strong
and sharp one
eventually some H5 can happen
freeing up the F5 Square for a night
let's say Magnus and his element there
so uh let's go back to the bird's eye
view or let's dive straight into the
game of the final round between Hikaru
and Nakamura who is in a must win
situation against Fabiana Carolina he
needs to win this classical game and
we've seen a few extra moves on the
board
yep a few extra moves on the board
nothing too dramatic happening both
sides just trying to find better squares
for their pieces but still two pawns up
for white and it looks like he has
solved one of the issues here uh Judy
Ivanka this white Bishop much better
place than it was earlier well actually
Black's uh position I believe it's
getting better and better the only
problem is some most bones are missing
because in the last move Bishop D6 was
played Knight to E7 so everything is
stabilized but uh yeah one more Pawn
would be helpful on B7 let's say and
then there would be full compensation
for black I believe
so black does not want to give up the
black Square Bishop he wants to keep it
because he knows it that if he gives up
maybe he has some drawing chances but
there are very little chance that he
will be able to hold it yeah he needs to
start Square Bishop at least for now to
defend the E5 pawn and it's a fabiana's
move he's done a good job of just kind
of sticking in there staying in the game
but what next how does he solve the
problem of this bishop which is
currently caged and The Rook stuck
behind it I would ask you why was Rook
C4 to C2
a good move what is the idea behind it
uh her car has lost me for treating this
white Rook back does he think that it's
a stronger
what's the idea
mysterious
and yeah let's just show this on the
board we were lost in this position
after the move uh Rook e to C1 just two
moves ago black did indeed Play Bishop
d6's due to mentioned defending
everything and the bishop did drop back
and Rook
four to C2 I was gonna say Rook C to C2
but they're two Rooks on the C file so
it's this one recruiting
what could be the idea there's no way
for this bishop to ever hit the Rook
because the White Knight guards any
squares that this black Bishop wants to
use I thought it might be some Knight E4
I know it doesn't scratch that the
knight's on E7
maybe for example as you say Ivanka he
was worried that black knight would come
round and jump uh kind of via F4 but now
he can move his Knight out the way
Knight E4 uh your idea and after it
takes okay actually I don't need to be
flashy here I can just take this bishop
first with a check and next move
Sports export
three pawns up this time
so maybe just jumping out the way there
of some potential attacks some potential
hits on this white Rook maybe he thinks
he has the luxury of uh time here black
is not breaking out anytime soon or
creating any threats of his own
yeah black really has a problem with a
light squared Bishop
I mean
it just feels like a no version of the
universe is that getting out and just to
mention the idea that you flagged up
earlier Ivanka if you ever push the F
Pawn yes you have kind of new squares a
new lease of life for this bishop but
you also lose uh control over E4
and there's some questions about whether
white can strike immediately with D4 for
example right now
hmm well maybe instead of f4 what about
black playing H6
I'll play a I'll play copycat H3 so you
don't background check the white king
later
okay Rook B8
the waiting game
not to be confused with the ivanka's
book The Mating Game
uh Rook to B8
uh it's a question how either side
improves
I want to get this white knight around
somehow I want to strike with D4 but D4
is always met by E4 as we showed earlier
well maybe
unless the idea is to go D4
is this one of hikaru's ideas uh the
four and E4 Knight D5 yeah and now maybe
this is the difference because the white
Rook on C2 protects the D2 Pawn I'm not
sure I'm so happy for what uh plan if it
goes here of course it would be nice for
black to move away somehow back move
away with the rook and the centralize
the Knight on D5 which is not gonna
happen
in the near future
chaos like you say this black Rook is
kind of entrenched in the center it's
kind of trapped here and white will mean
well played D3 and trade even more pawns
off the board getting ever closer to
Victory
maybe this must I mean no other logical
explanation that we found so far Rook C2
well it's also that it's not easy to
make a move for black
it's a bonus
34 minutes for Fabi
it's difficult he's still recovering
from that blow of course earlier in the
opening but
even now he's done a good job of
surviving but what next
I'm just gonna have to try step by step
move by move stay in the game
and no easy task also generally speaking
it can be an idea to move back The Rook
to C2 that once you jump away with the
Knights so Bishop A6 does not come with
a Tempe that's the only other thing I
can think of but you don't want to move
away with your Knights right
to give away that full control over the
C8 Bishop
do you think we'll see it now D4 from
Hikaru fabi's played one of the moves we
mentioned without the insertion of H3
and H6
to B8 has landed
and hey Karu he will reveal his plans
shortly
but Hikaru also like you guys have
pointed out can just enjoy
this position and play those luxury
moves exactly as you suggested age three
and then D4 and then
it's so difficult to think of a move for
black you know I've been trying to think
what is the best case scenario no he
goes for it immediately before yeah
I mean what is the best case scenario
for Fabi and that would be trading off
into an opposite color Bishop end game
or getting some activity on the light
squared and you just can't get there
you need a lot of things to go your way
you need all the chips to fall on your
side here just to try and survive this
one D4 it's important that the White
Knight has a nice powerful outpost on E5
and yes it can be traded off but that
only
straightens out the white Pawn structure
he's trying to get rid of his weaknesses
here and Hikaru the white Double D pawns
were
yeah just clear targets now they might
possibly become strengths
am I looking at it the more I like it
for weight but it did feel
counterintuitive to kind of block
White's Bishop at least it looked like
it was exerting pressure on black Santa
now it will be
a bit stuck for a while yeah because
having both nights so much in the center
on E5 and C5 if we can dive into some
lines after E4
Knight E5 of course it's very difficult
for black now to to play because one
night will stay for sure right either
night you're taking the other one stays
very much in the game and paralyzing
Black's opportunities
yeah this poor Bishop anytime it tries
to come out there another Knight comes
in to cover its Escape squares and yeah
just D3 at the right moment if you time
it right we'll break down Black's
Central pawns chain it looks like a car
is still in full control
um D4 nice move
it's a very nice move not wasting time
with H3 and playing Just moves waiting
moves
I don't know I kind of liked the
patience policy
but sometimes you don't have time or
also sometimes you may ruin your winning
positions by saying okay I make this I
have time for this move that move
whatever and sometimes you really have
to make the move go straight forward if
that's your plan make D4 go Knight D5
and go straight forward because why why
do you need H3 so it's uh it depends on
the position but you have to know what
you're doing and you have to make it
under control not just making moves
well Hikaru seemingly in full control
against Fabiana Carona and it's the
perfect time to jump to a break and when
we get back we'll have more of this very
important game and of course the
Armageddon between Wesley and 17 year
old kukesh so stay tuned
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
[Music]
thank you
oh my goodness Knight d8 whoa
he voted me with me the chance Rook F7
oh no
no no
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
excitement of the final round of Norway
chess and we're going to dive straight
back into the Armageddon game between
Wesley so and go cash
there we can see the players all making
their moves as quickly as possible
but it has been a disastrous start
through this Armageddon game from Wesley
so he missed a tactic just as we jump in
and look at this Queens are off the
board minor pieces off the board and
what are we left with it's just an equal
end game and yeah just this is not what
he had in mind needing to win with white
not exactly I believe that yeah this
simplification was blundered it's not
giving extra chances for black but it
did made the pieces cut off from the
board with this Knight E4 idea well
Wesley will still fight play D4 Knight
C4 possibly somehow to play Knight E4 to
F5 play H4
well some positional ideas but of course
go cash will have to make huge blunder
to ruin the equilish position that is
all true but Wesley does have something
up his sleeve he has some extra time on
his clock because he did start with an
extra three minutes perhaps he can use
that to his advantage and there we can
see cash has just under six minutes to
Wesley's eight minutes and 15 seconds
yeah Wesley needs to complicate things
somehow give gokish difficult decisions
to make up to this point it's been very
quick from the Indian teenager for
impressive stuff now he's just going to
bring his Rooks to the center
there we go he'll improve the black king
decide where to put his pawns most
likely black will put his pawns on light
squares to complement his dark squared
Bishop wow Wesley offering a trade of
Rooks here
and if we see all the Rooks come off the
board
it looks like the position will just be
a dead draw
well we are heading very much towards uh
simplification taking off swap The Rook
on E1 and rookie eight though I'm not
sure black will be in a rush to take on
E1 because what he is he's in a rush on
the clock maybe that's why okay and I
predict that all the Rooks will leave at
the board but uh Wesley banking on the
fact that his Knight is much more
flexible than the bishop but it's going
to be an uphill struggle because there
are no more porn majorities on the board
whatsoever
yeah the only real imbalance here are
blacks sea pawns but in this position
they do they don't really uh kind of
ruin anything they don't compromise
Black's chances because they are nicely
protected and white has no potential
past pawns uh no weaknesses in the black
cap I'm wondering what the Wesley so has
in mind in such a position that oh what
a Pity that I've landed it's a dead draw
but I cannot agree to a draw I have to
pretend that I'm fighting
right because what is this you can't
agree to draw which which gives you zero
point
um so it's it's kind of difficult to
make yourself keep yourself serious
about it
I'm just gonna be even more to God after
I've played that c Pawn forward offering
a trade
I mean the only option is for him just
to flag good cash well and first he has
to play D5 for sure I believe
yep
and this kind of stuff it's also with
the King and then C6 yeah but it's not
so easy to flag go cash we've seen him
uh having less seconds than Fabiano for
example and playing faster so
[Music]
and he has a very good uh
intuition of Fortress so he's going to
be very fast I believe
it feels like Wesley needs to take some
chances if he wants to win this game
pushing forward with D5 at least locks
things down on the light squares you ask
the dark squared Bishop whether it's
really going to sit there stuck the rest
of the game you need to try something
trading these pawns off or allowing the
capture on blacks terms doesn't look
promising just total symmetry there and
okay he just brings his King forward
okay slightly more active King slightly
more active minor piece temporarily but
how are you going to probe a Black's
Pawn structure he tries to get to F5
with his Knight or to B5 possibly and
maybe trying to make a good cash to make
a decision to First do you want an end
game opponent game because that can be
very tricky time to time so it's you
have to have all the self-confidence to
defend that but I believe after Knight
F5 maybe black will just go Bishop faith
and Jesus exactly and okay so whilst
this one is looking comfortably like a
draw for good cash which is what he
needs
well we do have breaking news if we go
back to the bird's eye view take a look
at the position between orientari and
Ali Reza faruja there on the right the
bar is all the way up in White's side
which means that Ariane has a huge
advantage
on home soil ariantari could be the only
Norwegian to strike with a classical
Victory unless Magnus Carlson shapes up
and yeah it looks like Ferris is just
taking a huge chance which shouldn't pay
off
there's a big gamble can Ariane convert
his Advantage it's not obvious to the
naked eye it's not obvious at first but
it looks like here white is doing
extremely well because this is the line
which we went all the way through I
believe but he didn't take the Knight on
F7 but he went on with his D1 Knight to
capture the pawn on D6 and suddenly the
White Knight on D6 creating uh connect
uh protect his post spawn on D5 can give
fight some interesting
opportunities though I don't understand
why the bar is so optimistic
it's not quite trapped it can Retreat
via A4 or C4 so that black knight can
get back in the game there is an attack
there's a hit on this pawn it is a bit
mysterious why white is doing so well I
like White's position General this black
Bishop is just terrible but
yeah it feels like a huge Gamble from
ferrugia against the tail Ender of the
tournament could we see this backfire he
looks calm as he gets up
not easy not obvious it's not obvious at
all and I just checked with the Oracle
that is the computer and it says that
white is winning after a very nice
Bishop maneuver moving the bishop to A2
wow that's deep maybe lining up some
tricks on this diagonal and the whole
point is that once you do that then you
put a rook on the C1 line I mean it
makes sense when the computer suggests
it but is it easy for a human to see
maybe maybe not yeah maybe not uh for
example black and winter Pawn Rook Chase
porn but now white simply conquers the C
file under CC Ivanka for example if
black is a bit uh too helpful here then
white is going to break through uh on
the C file yeah this takes some
compliance from black but looks good
looks promising this what night too
strong I think before uh we were
discussing this I don't know if we were
on air or off offer that it is very
typical that the the underdog plays very
badly with bad result and then finally
uh he beats let's say the best player
and it happened with the story that he
beat similarly he played pretty badly or
he was not scoring much and he beat
Magnus Carlsen so this is a typical
tournament scenario in some tournament
and there we can see Ariane didn't spot
one of the most effective ideas and
played The Rook to A2 chasing away the
Knight which is very natural but as you
can see the bar is leveling out and
don't forget that before in several
games he was not very fortunate having
his Bishop on A2 or A7 so oh the irony
of it all and once it would be standing
so well there he missed it
the weight development's there let's see
if Ariane can somehow get that Advantage
back or capitalize on this Advantage
Black's Knight now is out still looks
pretty promising for whites especially
with this strong past D Pawn but a lot
of twists and turns ahead that's for
sure
okay so uh shall we head back to the
Armageddon game where the players are in
their final few minutes
yeah very fast game that between Wesley
and good cash but it has changed it has
developed slightly and I'm not sure
about kakash's decisions he has planted
his pawns on dark squares the same color
as this bishop meaning he's vulnerable
on the other color complex the light
squares this time white snipe will
eventually try and maneuver itself
around to some more promising pastures
uh Judah are you surprised by what's
happened here
well yeah after B4 right after C4 B4 uh
White can dream of some better location
for his Knight D5 or E4
he plays A3 look at that
uh-huh
slightly odd there I don't know I was
I'm kind of surprised on that move but
maybe he did not want to leave any
opportunity for the black Bishop to
attack the B2 Pawn now I guess King E4
is a must because otherwise black starts
to move King E5
King is coming if White's Knight could
somehow just position itself on D5
everything would be under control but uh
yeah this is slightly annoying that the
black king is coming in okay he goes the
other way he's trying to jump into C6
tries to catch some Pawn over there yeah
I'm trying to invade
this is a vulnerable Pawn but maybe it
can just move one square
or the bishop can hit the Knight and if
you jump forward you might get trapped
yeah because after Knight C6 I think
black just goes A6 and after that game
D6 White Knight can get in trouble
I like that Bishop C7 move back you go
my friend and uh there's the Knight does
retreat
good time we've seen this position how
is white going to
actually improve there's some pawns
relocate the knights and there we see
good cash also initiating another Pawn
trade
yeah pawns are flying off the board and
that is not good news for Wesley so who
needs to win uh yeah five it looks like
black is just trying to create Pawn
imbalances on both sides remember the
bishop is stronger when there's pawns on
both flanks Black's King can always
start the race as well in race territory
Bishops tend to be superior to Knights
I don't see any way in for the white
knight uh this white knight lacks a nice
path to any promising squares
okay there we go again trying again from
A5
still trying probably after Bishop C7
Knight B7 might be something to try out
but after that it seems also Bishop B6
and the Knight can be trapped
that's very dangerous at the same time
after F5 you can take on F5 King F4 King
F5 and start start sneaking in with your
king and you have a pass spawn on the f
and anyway white cannot lose anything
right he has to go for double or nothing
yeah he needs to gamble here but this is
the moment of truth will Wesley Retreat
and admit that he's not getting anywhere
this game is likely to fizzle out to a
draw or is he gonna run in with his
Knight and yes it might get trapped yes
it might have to sacrifice itself but it
will come at the cost of time for black
what do we think forward or back forward
oh it goes back we pronounce it note
back to B3 putting all his pawns on
light squares now Wesley so but still he
needs targets not easy to find them
I like this move from gokesh the pawn
will be difficult to attack on A6 but
now he wants to go maybe bishop C7
Knight B7 and A4 is there already to
play A5 in the next move
but uh the Knight on B7 isn't the most
active piece and you can just simply
maintain connection with the bishop to
go to maybe
I don't know E7 or something
yeah what is black gonna do it's his
move he can just pass
and bypass we mean make a non-committal
move he goes back with the King taking
away at least the C6 Square from White
tonight so it does jump into B7 you can
always run back so not trapped yet
finally reach the B7 Square
the big question is what has this
achieved
does white have a breakthrough on the
other flank this Knight is acting as a
distraction deflection that the black
king is still within touching distance
of its own points
it's like very solid difference from
defense from uh go cash so far clock
times are basically level right now it's
a sudden death finish one minute each
nice move there making sure the white
king cannot come forward the black
Bishop cuts the diagonal but uh maybe
Wesley had a chance to trade pawns and
then do the Knight B7 idea
you can go back in that direction he
might try that again
oh now he's going in a different route
with his Knight
still not sure where it's headed and
that's your he knows where he's headed
but he has to try maneuvering trying out
to have it on day three on C3 on D5
practically every Square on the board
going passive is he hinting that he
might start running with the black king
over towards the white a pawn if the
white knight Strays too far
looks like he's at least trying to scare
Wesley here I think he just wants to go
back and forth E6 and D7 keeping the
everything how it is
just kind of repeats
yo-yo rotate around these squares
not commit too much
he's spending a lot of time suddenly go
cash it looks like he's starting to fear
some poor name games maybe as you
mentioned Judah if the Knight for
Bishops if the knife of Bishop trade
happens oh and uh there we see gukash he
is ticking under 25 seconds remember the
players only get a one move sorry one
second increment after move 40 and no
gukesh is ambitious he's gonna run with
his King to B6 and perhaps gobble up the
a pawn
it's a race now this black pawn will
become extremely strong of the black
apron and knights are notoriously bad at
stopping those pawns but white will have
some fun on the other flank on the other
side of the board well I think now it's
really getting hard the question is what
happens after Knight F4 black I think
has to take on F4 take stakes and
whether King B6 is black going to be in
time
that's the big question Black's King is
going to go and Gobble up the a pawn but
it takes a long long time and he trades
first and Wesley also
22 seconds
oh we oh this is getting intense
yeah he's going after the F Pawn he's
won the F Pawn now Wesley so but the
black Bishop is so agile defends
everything blocks the past white F Pawn
and I fear actually for Wesley now
because this Pawn is dropping and
White's night is so far away from
preventing Black's apron from running
the king will instead block
yeah it feels like Akash is the one
playing for a win but uh watch the
clocks everyone because good cash has 11
seconds and Wesley all down to Wesley
has three seconds too
just gotta try and flag black but there
is a trick playing F6 in the next move
uh White's running out of Pawns though
he's gonna try Black's Bishop gives
itself up there's a night Fork but the
king can come all the way towards to the
H3 so white will not be able to and
Wesley two seconds oh and he won't be
able to keep his Pawn alive we see the
draw agreed I go cash takes the
Armageddon
so on uh that's lost on time ah either
way go cash takes the Armageddon yes
oh good cash you know he's running
Magnus a close rival in the Armageddon
this matches because you know he got
five points out of six against again the
one some of the world's finest players
what a talent is the 17 year old
write things from him and there we see
the players on the camera leave the
board and gukash walks away with one and
a half points so he has now 14 and a
half points in the standings
yeah Hikaru Nakamura will have seen that
result and know that if he doesn't win
this game kukesh might well end up in
second place
uh so where to go next we see the bird's
eye view we see all the boards action
everywhere
can we go back to Hikaru just a little
bit because these spawn exchanges
changed quite a bit the on the whole
position
because there was an exchange of Bones
the D4 to the E5
it was exchanged and interestingly
enough the
white piece went back I don't know if
after he takes D4 what happened can we
go back for a few moves
and just to see after D4 black played e
takes D4 let's show this on the board
Action Replay
and
with which piece he took with the bishop
or the Knight he took with the knights
and just to show we basically reached
the same position in a few moves that we
have now except White's deep pawn and
the black E Pawn disappearing clearly
this is a big gain for white White's
deep on was weak so after default it was
traded the White Knight recaptured and
after the move A5 Hikaru simply stepped
back out of the way he thinks he has
another Pawn so he's going to play D4
and Knight D5
you don't succeed the first time try
again he's got a backup well isn't this
his plan
yeah after H6 is his move we'll find out
D4 plant a knight on an outpost in the
center
it's very much a pikaru street that type
of move just full control
well of course at first it does not look
necessarily the the most tempting to
play D4 and block The Bishop's power
there but it is also tempting to really
to centralize the other night into the
center to E5
he could also take a time out I guess
play a move like H3 or H4 and just pass
the move back to Fabiano but it feels
like if you have something productive to
do you might as well do it okay for the
first time in a long time this black
light squared Bishop can breathe because
white has retreated back to A4 yeah but
I believe Nakamura has a serious plan
playing Knight C3 and putting the D5
Rook into a difficult position because
they're born on A5 so black cannot
escape to the A5 square and then it can
get in trouble
in different ways
so let's say if we can go into some line
and we go Bishop A6
then I believe Knight C3
and Rook C5 is not possible to Bishop A3
and you don't want to exchange the dark
Square Bishop with black
because it's a huge Advantage for white
I mean it's an improvement technically
to win it and if Rook D3 then Knight E1
I believe
running out of Escape squares I have to
go to defense D4 Knight B5 winning
material hit this bishop hit this rook
and if Rook D5 then takes on D6 and
Bishop E5 right
skewer
yeah this all seems like it's working in
White's favor the tactics and right now
all the tricks
Hikaru a tricky guy Knight A4 nice move
threatening to come back
and corralling this rook in the center
just looks like even with his Bishop
released Fabi still has insurmountable
problems
to deal with
I don't envy him the task do you have to
move this bishop out the way create an
Escape Route for the black Rook to
retreat but even that is sad you don't
want to worsen your pieces just to run
away but uh where are you going to run
away with a dark Square Bishop
that's the other big question because I
was looking at that and I was I don't
see a good Square yeah you've got to
choose one of these two but you'll get
hit by points
not looking promising at all this bishop
this Rook everything a bit stuck in the
center white Snipes are dropping Black
Goes F4 making space for his Bishop on
F5 then also Knight C3 and if Black Goes
let's say Rook H5 then Knight E4 can be
very powerful and uh
the D6 Bishop gets vulnerable
yeah looks like a killer threat Knight
to C3 right now
wow
well do you want to hear what Hikaru has
to say for himself because he is back in
the confessional and this time taking a
deep dive into his game and sharing some
of the crazy lines that he's calculated
and also some that our very own dude it
also hinted at so Hikaru let's have a
listen
welcome back everybody so I just spent a
lot of time on his last move my current
game I was thinking for a very very long
time about playing this movie knight to
E6
um it felt like the right move but then
I started looking at more I saw a lot of
complications with lines like um
Knight to E6 Bishop Bishop takes a three
Knight C7 and then Rook d798 Bishop B7
and Rook C6 Bishop B7 as well once I saw
these really long complicated lines I
just sort of started looking at this
move rookie C1 instead because on top of
keeping all the pieces on the board
black still doesn't have an obvious ID
and I remain up two pawns here so I
don't know if rookie soon was best or at
90s I mean I think 90s might have been
winning on the spot but again like I
don't really want a lot of the
complications if I can avoid now Magna
said something about this the other day
about like trying to win the games
without allowing counter playing if you
can you want to avoid it but it's not
always guarante you can't always
guarantee to yourself that you will
avoid it but at any rate I mean I saw
Ricky see when Rook B8 and then Bishop
B2 and the night before I spent a lot of
time looking this Knight before A3 line
I think that I'm just better there
um again I mean the good thing about the
position is basically Fabiano has used
time he is to find some concept here and
I'm not even sure they really exist in
this position and if they don't exist
he's just gonna lose the game so I still
feel pretty good about it but that's why
I use so much time on this last one so I
just want to make sure because if I go
if I go 86 and I'm wrong I could end up
in trouble whereas with Rook C1 repeat
Bishop B2 I maybe there's some way for
Fabian to keep the game going in an
unpleasant end game but in no world
should he ever ever have chance of maybe
trick me or Swindle me so I'm still
pretty happy with everything and I still
have a good time Advantage so it's all
feeling I feel pretty good about where
things are right now and obviously for
me it's the only only thing that matters
is my game so we'll see how it goes but
so far it's looking good so I'll be back
later
questions
there there we see a confident Hikaru in
the confessional Booth he did calculate
a lot of lines I mean that is one
hikaru's biggest strengths he's a
fearsome calculator but he was uh he was
very rational on deciding whether to go
this way or that way and I said no I
don't want to blunder I don't want to
get any surprises and after Rook ec1 is
just a very logical very clear move and
let's see if it's going to be just a a
great end game and he was very smart on
that
yeah that that does kind of uh show as
well the top players they're extremely
good at calculation they're extremely
good at attacking but they use their
calculation they use their tactical
skills in order to know when to push
when to take a step back when to just uh
kind of do nothing keep control and uh
hikara is kept full control in this game
he's done the hard work he's won two
points why go flashy uh slow and steady
often wise here and before the break we
would say or before the confessional
sorry we were saying Knight C3 is a big
threat
struggling to see a response an antidote
to that one
and on the issue of calculation
is it true that once you spot a move a
top Grand Master will actually look at
reasons why not to play that move so
they kind of calculate for
not for positive reasons but for
negative reasons
well I think uh as we discussed it
before it is very difficult to make the
right and the best choice and decision
in a winning position or when you have a
huge Advantage this is an extra skill
you have to develop you know that one
stage is okay what opening I'm going to
be playing what happens when it's a
debate whether I go to the sharp or the
more positional way but also when you
get the an opportunity and you have a
huge advantage or a winning position
then you have to switch your mindset to
something else because you did the
perfect job until that point and then
you have to know you have to know also
your opponent where he can feel that he
has
counter chances one of the best example
I had for example when I played the one
of my best game of my life against Anand
back in 1999 in those Hermanas I was
having a great game with two-piece
sacrifice in the opening it was a theory
but later on I went in a very good game
and their move 36 or at some point I
played this move B3 even it was still
almost all the pieces are on the board
but I knew that I don't want to
calculate here because after B3 he's
just paralyzed it's took swung he cannot
make a single reasonable move he will
have to worsen his position
and I felt it during the game also that
after B3 this quiet move he kind of gave
up and later on with his uh trainer I
was talking and he said well when you
played V3 it was over
the opportunity or in his mind that he
he can save the game simply you know so
sometimes small quiet or simplification
kind of decisions can be much wiser than
just go the sharp and I want to show off
that I calculate everything but one of
the main reasons why you're thinking
this way is because you're thinking
about what your opponent is doing and
you're trying to limit the possibilities
so for instance when we see this Knight
C3 immediately would you both think okay
what can black do how can what do they
like to do and then how does he think
that there is some chances exactly this
is the thing that in some cases like in
this position you think okay I have two
pawns down but still I have the bishop
pair the D2 Pawn is still there there
are no pass phones yet which is
dangerous I can have my knight on D5 so
there are still things going on but then
can be a scenario where you say two
points down hopeless it will be maybe
painful and I can play on for a long
time but there is no way I'm going to be
saving it yeah
yeah and uh Hikaru is thinking about the
opponent you mentioned it Ivanka and
he's probably thinking every single move
the top players always do like what has
changed what does black want here black
wants to get active with his pieces and
of course he's prepared this hit on the
black Rook you know what maybe what he
can want after Knight C3 Rook C5 and
after Bishop is three Rook C3 yeah I was
working that out it doesn't work why not
because uh I think you can go Bishop
takes Bishop yeah Bishop takes Bishop
brooksie to Rook C2 and then Rook C8
maybe if we can show it on the board
also Knight C3 yeah here Bishop A3 Rook
C3 TC3 this could well happen Knight C3
is on the board and here your anchor you
just want to take back this C5 is on the
board yeah
so we could see this position right and
I thought that they still have a problem
of two-point deficit well maybe three
because I wanted to go Rook C8 and then
probably you take take and Bishop C7
whoops things don't look good yeah when
it rains it pours and not just one Pawn
it's two and possibly three so uh this
is the position after Knight C3 Rook C5
immediately from Fabiano and yeah after
Bishop A3 he must just be intending to
drop back with his rook and hoping to
defend this position after the bishop
trade but now as he said Judith no
Bishop pair for black any chances at
least he's activated this piece
Knight A4 back to C5 can be a nice move
that's uh yeah nice and statistic just
like your B3 moving space freeze on the
board yeah so this type of position once
the Knight finds a nice safe Square all
of the dark squares will belong to White
it's going to be slow but it's going to
be
steady progress here for white and yeah
of course targets as well
let's go back to the game the players
are playing very fast at this point
Bishop A3 met by Rook C6 and at Bishop
trade in a minute
yeah
yeah that's poor Fabiana is just at the
moment at least unable to get his game
going but he's sticking in there he's
fighting he's uh of course for a
tenacious Defender
maybe he'll get some chances later if
he's patient if he's uh slightly
fortunate
yeah he will have to be a little bit
Lucky in this position and it does look
like Hikaru it's in full control and
remember Hikaru is two pawns up and
there we see the bishops get traded off
and
it's really difficult to actually kind
of come up with like good saving moves
for for Fabiano because his position is
ultimately lost and there we see your
move on the board so the night going
back to A4 branded statistic
but David but chess is a cruel game it's
not about uh being caught into your
opponent
um so this is looking like one-way
traffic in hikaru's favor shall we go
back to the bird's eye view and have a
look at some of the other games
yeah there have been huge developments
in the game between uh Magnus Carlsen
and nordebec dusotourov that one has
really simplified and not necessarily in
magnus's favor you can see on the camera
there the body language Magnus looks
frustrated he just doesn't look as
energetic as we're used to seeing from
him and the position reflects that it
feels like Magnus was turning the screw
he was doing everything right had the
bishop pair uh had Pawn pushers on both
flanks but maybe he rushed it and uh
Notre back just finding really nice
resources to simplify down in a
promising position for black perhaps
well somehow it leaks it looks uh really
difficult for black for white what about
Rook E4 and taking the pawn on D4
yeah he could have gone over the spawn
he goes B5
should we do a quick action replay of
what happened we've had four or five
moves since we last left the position
and things have utterly completely
changed here uh let's just quickly jump
in we saw it after the move H4 white was
about to play H5 black stepped back with
his Knight and here I would have just
assumed Magnus would trade these Knights
and maybe Parker Bishop 183 and very
solid still long-term Advantage but he
rushed with H5 and after Bishop A7
suddenly there are tactics against the
white King on this diagonal we saw after
a trade of Pawns and uh well it's a king
shifting that this trade of knights
allowed Knight G4 maybe what Magnus had
missed and suddenly the Black Knight
jumps in look at this double exclamation
mark the Knight is coming in and more
importantly The Rook is coming in with a
check
no Judith called this meant this tactic
like many many moons ago she said don't
put the King on G2 because there could
be some Knight G4 ideas with the Rook
coming to E2 yeah because I almost
missed it myself when I was trying to
miss something other I noticed this that
this can go wrong also
yeah Mike Magnus this must have been off
his radar until it was too late maybe he
spotted it just before it was about to
happen double exclamation mark
unexpected temporary sacrifice of course
Pawn takes Knight met very strongly by a
rook check a fork double attack
regaining the material uh here with
dividends uh instead Bishop takes G6
happened and after a rook check magnus's
King had to step back to the G1 Square
really uncomfortable here and King G7 we
saw a trade of pieces counter-attacking
against the bishop and this is the
current position Judah you mentioned
rookie four that looks extremely natural
to me I'm not sure why this wasn't
played because I believe that not their
back things that B5 simply even better
because he can go Rook E4 later and also
he thinks that Rook B2 can be very
unpleasant
white to take on V5 and if black can
create the past spawn that can be
something
decisive yeah don't take on B5 if you're
Magnus so at least don't take happily
because suddenly this black apron could
start running it promotes on a dark
Square as well helped by the black
Bishop
yeah scary because once you have the
your Rook on the second Rank and you cut
off the king you don't really want to
give up this and and go to play a rookie
E4 but with Rook E4 black could win the
D4 Pawn
yeah we should mention that magnuses
temporarily are pulling up but the
quality of these pawns is debatable
Magnus okay princess king king F1
well I mean obviously you want to go out
from the in as soon as possible Right
just to give yourself an opportunity to
save the D4 Pawn but also after B5 white
C6 Pawn is a weakness so Rook C1 can be
also a counter chance for white
yeah it felt like Magnus fighting for
his life a moment ago now we see no
dubeck prevent any hit on that C6 Pawn
by simply defending he's playing for
control here uh holding his C6 pawn and
still trying to create an outside pass
Pawn on the queen side
I don't like White's position here this
bishop hitting thin air this Rooks
passive well probably black wants to
take on A4 and Rook C4 in the next moves
threat B takes A4 and a double attack
with Rook C4
maybe white has to go hunting Bishop to
C7 try to track down this A5 Pawn
yeah that's not a bad idea at all I'm
slightly reluctant to allow the black
king in the black king might be
Unleashed if the white Bishop moves
I was also really reluctant
to uh just move the bishop one thing I
was thinking about was could uh
Magnus just kind of pull the break and
play like Rook D2
just to activate the King and I was
thinking that why not to play rookie one
and play for something interesting
very different styles
oh so I was on your wavelength fairly
Ivanka
trying to bail out with a cowardly draw
we all have our minds going on different
directions
but my first thing too was yours but
then I kind of got very scared because
if you moved to Rook to E1 you let go of
the D4 Pawn wow Rook D2 on the board oh
pull that break no uh it was scary
having that King cut off along the
second rank
Magnus yeah he wants to activate his
king of course if the Rooks disappear
then White's Bishop lands back on D2 and
hits the A5 Pawn so white should be safe
in that end game
for C3 then you want to go Rook H2 or
what is the plan
it's a big question I
think
Magnus might just move his King there
well I I thought after brick C3 you can
actually grab on
oh no no no I'm asking for trouble I'm
not gonna do that I think we go David's
idea of going Bishop C7
aha let's
okay let's wait for maybe uh not
effective player here if he wants to be
ambitious he'll play the move Rook C3 I
think no other way to play for a win
oh Rock C3 on the board he is playing
for the win
and the thing is black
the question is here is is he
threatening to take this Pawn or B3
because as soon as the Black Brook moves
White's Rook will slide across and hit
the C6 Pawn
really tough moment okay he does play
King E2 here Magnus King off the back
rank
I wanted to say active but that King is
still not active and Rook takes B3 will
be met very strongly by Rook to C2
but look at Magnus he was just staring
away from the board for a second there
he looks disgusted with himself because
he's the one fighting for the draw now
yeah but remember you know Magnus
there's Pride at stake for him you know
he lost his first game against Fabi then
he's drawn all the rest of his classical
games and he feels thwarted at every
opportunity I mean he's thrown away so
many great positions and this feels like
yet another opportunity that he let slip
Deja Vu for Magnus something just not
quite clicking in the classical portion
rating points disappearing as well but
uh
yeah still the Armageddon ahead
potentially if he saves this game and it
is an if at this point
well I think yeah that's the thing he's
thinking about already that okay bro
let's go
let's play the Armageddon that works for
me
[Laughter]
yeah and okay
should we stay on this game or should we
go back to the bird's eye view and have
a look at the other two games
I think back to the bird's eye view
there's action elsewhere uh if Magnus
gets Rook D3 next move if not if I
cannot find anything this game will end
in a draw will end peacefully and uh
yeah this action
I see tari is I just see the the
evaluation
in Whiteside absolutely but seeing that
eight A8 Bishop
biting into the D5 pawn it does not look
good
I guess that's that's like a running
theme for Arya
you know but this time he's on the right
he's on the right side exactly
he always has a bridge body too or A7
himself though White's Bishop not
impressive either but at least it can
break out Black's Bishop stuck in jail
in prison here for a long time and this
time he's not behind in time as he
usually in most of the games it was the
case
does he have a nice tactic a nice trick
up his sleeve as well I'm just wondering
what happens if black takes this Pawn
but I think his last move hits at the
fact he might try to break the blockade
of the C file uh he wants to get in with
the white Rook of course he wants to
infiltrate maybe he's simply planning to
put his Knight on B3 yes I believe so
after Rook F3 Knight B3 will come and
after takes Rook C7 will be a killer
yeah let's show that uh because for
Russia right now maybe he's
underestimated something he did not look
happy looking away at the camera that
Rook takes F3 Knight B3 and is this a
killer is there anything for black to
save himself just to show this is a
sacrifice the black Rook can take this
bishop of course at the end but
breakthrough the Black Knight Falls and
not just the Knight the bishop will be
trapped later on as well
this is just game over as you said
Judith this is game over because not
only the D7 Knight will be falling off
in the next move but within two three
moves also the A8 bishop and there is a
great pass spawn on D5 as just a bonus
if you need it later on it's obviously
it's better if it's there
so how can fruit even try to fight on
that final position we showed was uh
totally winning for white so that means
a massive threat on the board Knight to
B3 eliminating this uh Black Knight on
C5 what about playing Rook F6 first
attacking the Knight on D6 and once it's
moving away only after that capturing on
F6 on F3
yep Rook F6 I do wonder whether I can go
hunting for this bishop in some
variations I wanted to kind of go Knight
E8 I'm inspired by all your 90 ones this
one should uh to come around to C7 98
Rook F3
but maybe you do the same stuff right if
it might be three
might be three anyway
after Knight C7 Bishop B7 and at least
I'm alive for a few moves yeah I wanted
to come round like this and go on E6 to
kick this Knight away
okay that's not very pleasant for black
either sorry
this one by any means possible by any
cost to get the rookin probably after
Knight C7 I should be capturing on e4 or
something and
just let you to take the bishop
yeah that's a sad piece
it's probably better for black now it's
off the board you don't have to worry
about it anymore but still White's a
piece
C7 still coming it looks beautiful for
tarry just this idea of Knight B3 in the
current position
could be a Bone Crusher here not B3 if
it lands
farrugia pushing too hard yeah well
this was one of the perks of being an
underdog that you could simply allow
your opponents to come at you and then
get them on the counter attack okay
shall we go back to the bird's eye view
and have a quick peek at the shack Mama
jarov I'm sorry anishikiri against Shaq
mamajarov
and then I'd like to return to the big
encounter between hikara Nakamura and
Fabiana caruana
yeah and uh just like uh some of the
other games this one is now uh opposite
color Bishop position
but Queen's Rooks remain and Black's
King may be slightly more vulnerable has
less Pawn shelter in front of it Judith
what do we think here uh well Queens
remain good chances for Gary or just
balanced well I think there are great
chances for Geary he just played H3 look
at that quiet move he just wants to make
sure that one day he's not in trouble
with his back rack but of course you
visualize your Rook to be on G3 one day
the question is whether can black look
for counter chances and place his
rookton to G6 but still I have a serious
problem with the bishop on C8 for black
because if he cannot put it on the long
diagonal to B7 then
[Music]
or activate it by playing the pawn from
D7 to somewhere and then it's attacking
on H3 then black can be in trouble
though I think I see that he's busy
trying to clean his phone
is motto
3a2
only three squares away
yeah Gary needs to land something
otherwise he might become a bit
frightened I shouldn't forget he's going
down on time he has half of the time
then his opponent which matters quite a
bit because the players have no more
time only after move 40-10 seconds
extra per move
yeah there we see Gary attacking said
Queen and A4 Pawn
my one fear here is that after Queen to
B3 mamajarov uh if he's feeling peaceful
trying to trade the queens that maybe
Anish won't find any way to keep the
tension
something went wrong with white compared
to the position we've seen like seven
eight nine moves ago when the bishop was
blockading on D6 and black was very
passive on the king side there were huge
dangers
but something happened with black
control the Rooks are on the sixth rank
greatly placed and I have the feeling
that the G7 Pawn is uh is weak but I'm
not sure why it can really pinpoint on
it that uh
that can be a real problem I think what
white will do was actually just to
activate the Rooks you know they're not
working and so if you say for instance
you play Queen B3 I don't think you
should trade off Queens you should
I don't know move your queen somewhere
and then play Rook F to be one
so with the idea to get that Rook into
the game the question is I think if
after Queen B3 where the white green
will be moving away
do F5 to H5 only to C5 so provoke black
from A6 or E6 to move it and Chase it
with Rook C6 or uh black will be
actually doing
yeah maybe bishop B7 and there we can
see from the round scores that it was a
draw between Magnus Carlsen and nodabik
Abdul sotorov and that means we are
going to see another
Armageddon and it also sadly means that
uh well Magnus Carlsen finishing the
classical portion with a minus score
not winning any games there first time
since 2007 this has happened Magnus not
winning a classical game in a tournament
and uh yeah Armageddon incoming in
around 15 to 20 minutes
okay should we go back to our headline
Act of the day
between Hikaru Nakamura and Fabiana
caruana
some developments there
and on the camera we see uh yeah we see
the players now
what do we make of changes here one set
of Rooks have left the board since we
were last at this game this Knight is
making exercise all the way Knight day
fortnite C5 Knight A4 96 3984 93.
guarding the white Army on the queen
side it seems
unfortunately for black the two-point
deficit means trading pieces doesn't
necessarily guide you closer to safety
Bishop takes Knight here does wreck the
white Pawn structure but it also takes
away a valuable potential source of
counter play
what else black wants to get active with
the Rook but it doesn't feel like the
black Rook is getting in anywhere even
if you occupy an open file
okay well
ikaru is still very much in full control
as demonstrated by our experts and I
think this is the perfect moment for us
to take another break because time is
ticking down on all the games and
excitement we'll be building and the
final moments of the grand finale is
about to happen between Hikaru and
Fabiano so see you all after this break
foreign
[Music]
is anybody in snoops Camp playing chess
is that happening or not I haven't seen
it there's some smart people in the camp
so I wouldn't be surprised if people
are versed at it very uh a lot of
college educated people you know I
unfortunately am not one of those
sophisticated people that play chess in
the camp what you talking about man I
don't play chess
I mean you know how to play listen
there's a difference with knowing how to
start a car up and then driving Formula
One racing
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are back for the final round coverage
of Norway chess and there you can see
two of the tournament leaders Fabiana
caruana facing off with the black pieces
against Hikaru Nakamura who is in a must
win situation the bad news for Fabiano
is that he is two pawns down and his
position is quickly
oh
or maybe not quickly deteriorating
yeah two points down Hikaru is
threatening a third Point Hikari just
got up from the board very confidently
body language not positive for Fabiano
and to boot it's only 11 minutes left on
the clock
it's looking desperate now in the final
stages of this game
Judith any chances of Miracle here do
miracles happen for Fabiano well I see
less and less chance for Fabiano to be
able to save this game as it is a very
painful day for Fabiano it was only one
move one mistake which we can say that
it cost him the game most likely and
this F Pawn is not a lucky poem for him
because he just played F4 which was
probably not the best either and
immediately
uh Nakamura is attacking the F4 pawn and
it's hard to see how Fabiano can save
this one probably the only way is to
capture the Knight on F3 and after
taking to play G5 but all the
simplification favors Nakamura because
it's getting easier and easier to
collect the full point
yeah it's hard to add anything to that
it looks like I mean he needs something
he needs some resources but if he can't
save this Pawn then it's almost
resignable already
can't hide behind the fact that he
Hikaru is two pawns up and he's done
everything right it's not just that
Fabiana made that one mistake but Hikaru
has been brutal in punishing and uh
capitalizing on that and okay Rook to f8
a sad move there defending this Pawn yes
but now the black Rook is passive and
feels like White's night for example can
start jumping forward to E5
other ideas here the white Rook can
start collecting this a pawn soon well
also Fabiano went down under 10 minutes
black white can also go A3 for example
and then enter to D7 but maybe after
that Knight C2 Rook A4 so there are
still the only thing can go wrong for
Nakamura is from choosing the worst
moves of the good ones and then going
lost on that path but he has to make
many many bad moves or inaccuracies
first to ruin this winning position
yeah he's done the hard part Hikaru and
normally his technique and end games is
really top-notch it's exemplary and I
mean I've seen him on stream winning
harder positions than this so as long as
nerves don't get in the way unless maybe
the clock becomes a factor then he
should have this one in the bag I'm
expecting Knight to E5 I'm not sure why
it's just a Hikaru type of move I like
that move it's very active
straightforward going to G6 possibly
even having some very unpleasant
attacking ideas behind it but moreover
it wants to capture the F4 Pawn yeah
just to keep things simple here there
must be others there's probably a dozen
very strong moves here but which one
will Hikari go for uh it's just a matter
of taste at this point he's reaching out
it's just so confident he's used his
time really really well here as well
Hikaru there we go Knight E5 the most
logical move on the board Knight G6 is a
huge threat to pick up this F4 Pawn so
will we finally see F3
F3 every time he pushes the F Pawn it's
been a mistake because
at this point why not you want to play
F3 with black oh well I want to resign
is black but Fabiano needs to fight on
well maybe G5
support your pawns let's try to
Impossible
yeah the promise waits for Rook is going
to start coming and hunting
points Rook D6 Rook D7
of the white rook and knights combined
then Black's king is not safe either if
Hikaru gets time as well he would love
to play a move like F3 put the white
King on F2 and full control uh just to
blunder this bishop
wow what drama we did not expect this we
thought it would be a more topsy-turvy
game Hikaru would have had to take
massive risks it was just an inspired
opening Choice you've got to think
Hikaru made a fantastic opening choice
and he's so excited now I think it shows
his body language that he's like moving
a little bit here and there and he's
looking
uh and he's just waiting for black to
move he's getting impatient
is there any way that Hikaru can go
wrong
so anything tempting say for instance I
don't know what to suggest
G5 had problems as you pointed out okay
Rook E8 that's the move played
yeah so if a car Retreats this night
back to F3 the position repeats itself
but of course he will want to win and I
don't think it's too scary to let the
black rook in uh down to the White's
first rank because White's King has a
nice Escape Square
so white tonight can find I mean he can
get active I'm looking at Knight G6
as a potential
leaping point for this Knight you could
go the other direction you could go to
C4 uh start Pawn hunting here on A5
the question is is Rook check any uh
kind of Hope any counter play for
Fabiano or is it just a shot in the dark
well I believe Knight G6 is the best
move because after Rook E1 we can also
show it maybe yeah yeah let's show this
yeah if Knight G6
there is an option to play Rook E1 King
H2
and I was thinking to play Maybe Rook F1
with an idea after Rook F4 Knight D3 but
that would be also behind in tempos
Black because rook f8 and H5 and even
black would get Mighty yeah
oh and there you would find yourself
hooked into a mate
um okay so I was actually thinking if
the Knight does jump to G6 maybe F3 yes
maybe absolutely once in its life that F
Pawn can do a bit of good absolutely no
question about it that's the only saving
opportunity to to try
okay and let's say G4 yep I bypass your
Pawn oh the white king can sneak forward
if it really needs to
how to create counter play for black
well you can't
and that's the problem I mean if you
went G3 then there's a different matter
no now you go rookie one and after King
H2O Guru F1 and if King eg3 then you
give it check on G1 and then you go back
to F1
now the problem is there is check
checkmate threats
somehow you might get checkmated somehow
but at least at the moment the black
king can run towards the center
and you can get five yes exactly I've I
was looking for setting that one up and
again you're hooked into that mate
this reminds me of the Checkmate between
Ding and Yan uh doing a neppo at the
World Championship where the black king
was caught by a Rooker Knight at the end
or it was about to be with a queen
sacrifice Knight G6 just looks too
tempting all those kind of mating
patterns happening around the black king
caught in a net dream setup for Knight
and G6 Pawn on H5
yeah Hikaru just pausing here just
double checking there's no tricks no
counter play but it looks very healthy
just Knight to G6 simple and strong
yeah
we think Fabiano will battle to the very
end
well it will be very difficult for him
to give up this game
and uh
and he played so well in this tournament
basically he was playing well the
classical he played well the Armageddon
also some of the games but he didn't
have so much because he had five
decisive games in classical and with
this one most likely he is going to be
having the most classical decisive games
and it's gonna be six games for victory
and it's
it's very painful because like you say
Fabiano played exceptionally well and
just
two bad moves
I mean I wouldn't actually say the
second move was bad actually I I'll just
say that yeah it's just the first move
terrible move and that cost him
everything how is chess going to be fair
I mean he's going to be super annoyed
with himself and
well I I do hope that
if he loses he can't see the positives
yeah meanwhile we do see the armaged get
in game has commenced between Magnus
Carlsen and no deck Abdul sotorov and so
far it's a total repeat of their
classical encounter same variations same
opening down to a t Queens off the board
as well and
who will come with the bigger ideas
Magnus is happy to repeat because he did
get an advantage from that game even if
he let it go let it slip a bit later on
interesting that both sides are happy to
enter this
yeah I understand completely Magnus that
he wants to repeat this
he thought that he had a better position
which he had I believe and white can
press it quite convincingly here on both
sides
yep that Bishop pair as we saw a bit
earlier did look very promising until
Magnus kind of missed a trick Mr tactic
and Abdus tour of pounced uh guiding
that game towards the drawer so Magnus I
think this might be the first new move
that we've seen compared to the earlier
encounter some pressure on the White
Knight Magnus has to decide does he
allow the black Bishop to take this
Knight or does he move out the way
and opposing he's on what is it seven
out of seven now from armageddon's
Magnus Carlson can he make it the great
eight a perfect score there in the
quicker format at least that would be
some consolation for his classical
results
and at least yesterday when he
contemplated the thought he did at least
laugh about that
said well you know maybe he hadn't yet
decided what strategy to take
yes and meanwhile okay the bishop lands
on F5
putting some pressure on those Black
Knights hinting that Knight E6 will
happen uh there are night jumps all over
the place unless black trades off this
night in the center
but okay there we go it's committal yeah
he's done it
and uh on the bottom right you can see
the position between hikara and Nakamura
and Fabiana caruana and so far they're
actually following our analysis we
thought that this might be one of
Black's only tries to prolong the game
yeah he retreated his Knight to C4 in
that game but very very similar and
Hikaru still he could finish that within
a few moves we'll keep you updated with
any developments
okay what do you think here Judith
Bishops or Knights that's the question
you agree Ivanka
you know me I don't even need to ask but
these nights if they find nice squares
then maybe some chance of finding uh
back a bit later on
it is simply not going to be easy for uh
black to to find space for the knights
because the D7 Knight does not have too
much space and the F6 Knight can only
jump into E4
[Music]
if white can somehow manage to get the
move F3 and to prevent this black knight
from jumping in then that would be
extremely attractive yeah that's
definitely something would be on White's
favor
I wonder if Rook A3 will be a move and
play Rook B3
just coming back he wants F3 he wants
Bishop D2 and very slowly improve his
position G4 H4 and
yeah maybe very fast improve his
position already a threat a hit on this
A5 Pawn met by a counter-attack on D4
yeah it just feels uh maybe he'll turn
it around to maybe I'll do tutorial will
prove me wrong but it feels like he's
playing into magnus's territory it kind
of worked out the first classical game
but
heading into an end game twice against
Magnus and uh especially when you have
less time on the clock it's a very risky
decision by the young teenager and
meanwhile we should head back to the
Hikaru Fabiano Carana game because well
the pawn did reach F3 it promptly got
traded off and both players having a
roughly seven minutes on the clock
so it really is a question of survival
here for Fabiano two pawns down can he
achieve a miracle
he's fighting like a lion Fabiano we've
got a praise him for that he's fought so
well since his slip out there in the
opening and Hikaru now it's getting
slightly nervous you can tell a bit
tense very straight back to there uh
less relaxed than he was earlier
suddenly the black Bishop is in suddenly
some hints at a counter attack against
the white king
yeah the big question is of course
whether can white continue his plan and
after Knight C4 he just wanted to grab
the pawn on A5 can he do that because
that would be
something he does not take on A5 he's
more scared what's going to happen with
his King possibly he wants to activate
his King and play King H2 so that E5
Pawn can wait I can take it later
yeah nice controlled air self-control
from Hikaru not getting tempted by the
uh seemingly free porn on A5 instead
King G3 is coming to evict this black
Bishop maybe and if necessary he can
always just Retreat his Knight to E3
where it will cover all the squares so
not too much danger yet
Fabiano has seven minutes it's
definitely tougher to kind of keep
coming up with creative defenses rather
than uh hikaru's job of just mopping up
but at least black is not going to get
checkmated as we've thought if the
Knight would be on G6 but he has to be
look after his spawn because that would
be the third Pawn which he would be
behind
yeah you've got to cover the spawn maybe
therefore the Black Knight can Retreat
covering the pawn and hitting the white
Rook at the same time just a one move
idea White's Frick will most likely just
move and hit this black Bishop
no easy options here for Fabiano maybe
black should be playing Knight C2 and
after Rook F4 I'm going to say a movie
to Villa Knight E1 in order to after
Knight A5 to go back with the bishop to
A8 and make space for my knight to F3
the daily Occurrence at this point you
did a nice idea
and uh someone who is actually going to
leave Norway chess with a big smile on
the face is ariantari who as I speak is
about to give fourth mate to farrugia so
that game will be ending very soon and
our entire will be picking up a
three-point classical win
yeah and well done to him uh Norwegian
fans here in Stavanger will be very
pleased for faruga tough end to the
tournament but uh on the in general he's
played very well so Knight C2 on the
board Judith and like you say maybe just
trying to confuse the opponent that's
the type of thing you have to do
especially when the clock stick down
just scare them even if it's a bit of a
bluff I'm not sure that King H2 was the
right move but that was kind of a move
that I want to over protect every
possibility what what can happen to me
right but still I think Fabiano is
giving a great try because this is what
you have to do that you have to bother
the king you have to make moves which
can be dangerous and Rook D3 interesting
move because Knight E1 is not good
because Rook E3 and black would have to
exchange the Rooks so I'm expecting
Bishop A8
clearing the square uh just in
anticipation of Knight E1
coming around to replace the bishop on
F3
has to be has to be played has to be
done
still some chances still alive Fabiano
for now as the players stick down both
around five minutes 50 on the clock
hey Curry getting up to just check that
they're nearing or they've actually
passed move 40 now so they do indeed get
a 10 second increment after every move
Road history looks strange but at the
same time I think it's a it's a very
safe move because the Rook will be
standing extremely well and defend there
uh on E3 once the Knight will be moving
to E1
yeah
no Prejudice there I Hikaru happy to
play Clumsy looking moves because they
actually do a great defensive job he's
done the hard work to remember and about
to be three pawns up
Fabiano he's deciding maybe which way to
go back with his Bishop maybe H5 as well
a viable option
which direction you kind of want to keep
the bishop on the long diagonal it looks
more natural yeah and it looks gives
more
more danger feeling for white let's say
not really dangerous it's just
pretending to be dangerous at some day
well you've got to Spook your opponent
out threaten some ghosts and okay
what is we what are we going to see from
Fabiano who's now Tech to under five
minutes
uh this uh tournament Norway chess will
be decided very very shortly as the
players take down Bishop indeed on the
board now a bit of a threat at least a
scary one to deal with Knight E1 and
bringing it around to F3 with a check
how is Hikaru going to do with that
is he going to ignore it is he going to
reacting G3
I think profile move
I predict he's going to ignore it and
get greedy uh no he plays King G3 keep
it safe
very good he just doesn't want to see
give check by Fabiano but now maybe King
H7 and then Rook E6 Rook G6 trying to
to make things funny
yeah at least with some ideas of tracks
it's got to be done at the moment okay
King H7 you're reading the place mind
student well you have to try to give a
check to Hikaru you can see that he's
just avoiding that he gets a check
both sides avoiding getting a check the
reason uh that blackplay King H7 is
because if you'd move the Rook last move
white would have given a check on the
eighth rank so Knight E3 now coming
round trying to force those Knights off
if possible Black's Knight is causing a
nuisance so it has to stay on the board
fabiana's only hope is either Knight to
E1 or going back via B4 but that feels
like it's the wrong side of the board I
think he definitely has to go to E1 and
after Rook D7 try Rook f8 back and give
it check on F3 the only aim is to give a
check to Hikaru that can easily be
parrot right when you put your Rook on
f8 there's a few way basically waving a
flag saying I want to check on F3 and
they will go no you won't because I can
push my F4 yes
white tonight is just going to be the
glue that holds everything together and
from that White's Rook will be released
White's pawns will come forward and yeah
if necessary one of the white Knights
can block this black Bishop's diagonal
later on yeah it feels full on now for
Fabiano but he's got to play 91 this is
the only active move in the position
it's the best hope everything's losing
he knows that as well he's just trying
to think in Practical terms and in
Practical terms he has to also move
faster
is it a good idea to actually burn the
time on the clock and at least
kind of create some excitement on the
board and hope that hikara gets carried
away
um Hikaru leaving the board so I don't
think Hikari is the kind of player to
get flustered at all if anything Hikaru
gets better as the opponent's clock
ticks down we've seen that all in his
splits and Rapid performances and yeah
just a power move getting up five
minutes on the board not five minutes on
the clock but no nerves at all and he
goes back like before
okay feels like the wrong direction Rook
D6
immediate reply just stopping that idea
dude no checks at all he's allergic to
allowing any checks on the white king he
just does not want to see a single chat
check given to him
and look at this Black Knight it's
totally trapped actually it's totally
dominated apart from the C6 Square only
one square back for it
this black Bishop as well hitting thin
air what to do
two minutes now for Fabiano
how long can you keep this tournament
alive
feel the tension in the air totally and
you really feel for Fabiano
I mean I've said it time and time again
the night does retreat but Fabiano has
played an exceptional tournament and it
all collapsed on account of one
blunder
and that's it
yeah small margins at this top level and
that's all it takes sometimes the Killer
Instinct the technique of these top
players is yeah just first class and
Knight C6 he's trying to get around I
believe the E4 can be a quite convincing
move and playing D5 afterwards blocking
the bishop on A8 oh he's reaching for
the night yeah he goes Knight D5
these nights are strong he's threatening
to go Knight C7 yes
that night has moved a lot in this game
this night was the one that captured
that key C5 Pawn earlier it's done yeah
it's done a tour of the whole board Cafe
the black Rook has to move there's a
night Fork threatened on C7
Fabby moves his Rook
and now how to kill the game
is he gonna keep jumping with his
Knights is he going to push some pawns
probably might be six Bishop B7 Knight
D7
yeah I feel like now is the time to push
some Pawns
and I I I feel like four exactly he
doesn't want to allow the opportunity of
black to play Rook F3 so kill it
and
well Hikaru is simply enjoying his
position
four and a half minutes this is not
nervous this is just a calorie
calculating trying to find the quickest
finish the smoothest finish with no
counter play
and there we can see the results of
another game Anish giri and Shakura
mamajarov did play out to a draw and so
that means we'll also be seeing our
third Armageddon
and that one will be wild and actually
Magnus is in trouble as far as I see
Abdul soturov is making a good game
actually he's also going to grab a pawn
so he is going to be able to draw the
game and when they are marked on yeah
and everything going wrong for Magnus
and we can see like Magnus is actually
down to seconds left on the clock
yeah Magnus in a worse position no
winning chances down on time
his Armageddon streak is going to be
over
well the young Talent not their back is
finishing his tournament very well
because yesterday he was able to win his
Armageddon against Nakamura
okay meanwhile moves on this board mcmur
jumps in with the white knight to C7
kicking that black Bishop away black
cannot allow any trades at all that will
just be game over White's pawns will
become too strong and now where is that
Knight jumping
the black pieces are hanging by a thread
the bishop protects the Knight but if
you can kick one of them away it might
just tip black over the edge maybe now
ivanka's F4 will stand on the board
finally yeah oh it doesn't look like
that he's he's reaching for another
piece okay he's attacked The Rook
he's attacking the black Rook where to
go The Rook wherever it lands might
simply get hit by one of White's pieces
okay Rook F7 covering the seventh rank
threatening at some points to move the
knights and still come in with a check
so I think now is the time for your move
your Banker I think so too because I
mean if you also try to liquidate with
Knight to d8 that would be a big mistake
but F4 finally on the board
and Knight to d8 is one of many tempting
opportun moves yeah 91 now we're seeing
Knight d8 is all these tricky night
jumps that the players have to be so
alert to with just two minutes against
three right now on the clock
how to prevent that if not to come off
Black's drawing chance of swindling
chances just simply disappear
but nowhere active to go Fabiano what to
do
he's got to move
now under two minutes Bishop goes back
to the corner
if Hikaru wants 98 is on tap forcing the
knights off the board
it just simplifies the equation
it's very strong you could also just
make an argument for pushing pawns
improving the White Knight here but no
he closes the cage around the black king
with H5
all sorts of meeting constructions now
and interesting that Nakamura is still
writing the
on the score sheet in under five minutes
they would not have to ride the move
anymore
yeah according to the rules of the
tournament he doesn't need to spend that
time notating the moves that's
interesting that he does Hikaru showing
his confidence looking away from the
board here looking up at the screen is
he watching magnus's Armageddon and
Hikaru is smiling I mean if we I mean
magnus's Armageddon is going to seconds
so I can imagine that Hikaru is
completely distracted by that
I mean both players with three four
seconds should we take a peek and see
what happens
some blunder or there's some
some drama in the Magnus Carlson against
Noddy back I've just a tour of game it
looks like has one of the players run
out of time no the game is continuing
and Magnus has turned it around uh no
wow just as we jump in Magnus flags and
loses on time he actually had a winning
position at the end there
this must be what Hikaru was laughing
about smiling about
well both players must have been playing
a Tempo bashing the clock moving the
pieces flying everything so I can
imagine Chaos on the board and of course
chess becomes a real spectator sport
when you have that situation Antico just
can't help himself
and this is the only game which is
happening in the playing Hall
right now between the two players who is
going to be winning the tournament yeah
imagine the spectators they're just
enjoying this moment Hikaru wow three
Judith this is exactly like your B3 that
you told the story about earlier
sadistic staff just showing that white
is in full control
and Fabiano with 35 seconds left on the
clock and the clock is the least of his
troubles as he tries to survive a
position where he is two pawns down King
moves to G8
this one looks beyond Redemption but
he's still fighting Fabi good uh
technique here instructor for everyone
at home never give up even if there's a
one percent chance you might save the
game decisive for the tournament now
well probably if the same position would
be round six let's say then there's a
good chance black would have resigned
already or at this point somewhere but
of course this is such a painful
situation for Fabiano who played so well
and won Incredible games in this
tournament starting out beating bangus
Carlsen in a classical game what the
game also later on the most exciting
sacrifice was happening against firoza
where with black he won the classical
game so now it's the one of the most
painful moments in his career I believe
definitely one of the best tournaments
Carolina's had in recent times and it's
about to end in heartbreak and uh okay
he plays Rook to E7 he made that move
with seven seconds left on his clock F6
and Knight F5 and I believe he's going
to play that
no way no calculation nothing it's just
improving the position
bringing the pieces slowly but surely
towards Black's half of the boards the
Deep Pawn is going to start running
White's extra pawns are going to count
and look at Fabiano
he's devastated staring away shaking his
head
now the white d-pawn comes
one of these moves is going to tip black
over the edge we'll see a handshake any
second now
the winner of Norway chess will be
Hikaru Nakamura and there we go it's
confirmed
wow
wow what a game a game but
Nakamura from an inspired opening choice
to provoking Fabiano caruana's terrible
one move blunder well Hikaru is Norway
chess winner
incredible achievement to snatch away
the glory from Fabiano Carona in those
last game
well we have to hand it to both these
Americans for giving us such inspired
performances
well it was breathtaking what was going
on today the way Hikaru was starting out
from his opening choice and after that
once he got the opportunity one mistake
was enough for karwana to practically
lose the opportunity to win the
tournament after the fact that he played
so well incredibly well and he would
have been deserving the victory but this
is chance this is sport where you make
one mistake and if you play against some
of the very best players in the world
sometimes it's enough one mistake to
lose all your hope yeah heartbreaking
and for Carolina but we also have to say
congratulations to Hikaru Nakamura you
know for his performance you know
remarkable that he didn't lose a single
classical game
he just kept fighting at every single
opportunity
and we saw simply this morning so this
morning this afternoon evening how you
know he focused he was to actually give
it his all and uh
try to beat Fabiano in their classical
encounter
and I'm just most impressed by the way
with which he just suffocated Carolina
there he got the advantage of course two
pawns up but he never once allowed a
check never once allowed a shred of Hope
or counterplay and
conversion just perfect yeah he was so
securing his point he did not make
anything which needed calculation once
he had two pawns up he was always
securing and little by little with great
patience he just converted his two
points Flawless performance by Hikaru
Nakamura and uh well he is 2023 Noe
champion and there's still one
Armageddon game remaining so we're gonna
take a short break and we'll see you on
the other side
International Master Danny wrench back
again Chief chess officer bringing you
chess terminology let's Dive Right into
one of one of everybody's favorite
tactics if I might be so bold because
it's surprising it's something that
never never fails to deliver shock value
and excitement whether you're watching a
broadcast or just reviewing some famous
chess games and that is the process of
an under promotion when you move upon to
the other side of the board almost
always you're looking to get a queen but
the rare times where it's better to get
something else or perhaps even required
in order to maybe not stalemate your
opponent or keep your winning chances
alive are some of the most fascinating
exciting moments in chess so with that
let's dive into what under promotion is
and show you some of my favorite
examples
under promotion as we said is the
process of promoting a pawn but not to
the most obvious or most powerful type
of piece which is usually the queen
in this famous example between Nakamura
and Vladimir kramnik the fact that
Hikaru was winning is only because he
under promotes on C8 to a night that
move comes with check on the black king
so that on the next turn white can
capture the E2 pawn it should be noted
that if Hikaru had queened
black would actually go on to win
because now black queens with check and
ultimately kramnik would have been able
to not just save but actually win this
game another promotion tactic provided
to me by our own Sam Copeland vice
president of content one of his favorite
examples is the move D7 and after Bishop
to E8 the only way to win the game is to
underpromote to a bishop under voting to
a bishop doesn't happen that often in
this particular study it was designed to
be so the point is that if the bishop
moves over to H5 we check and mate along
the A4 EA diagonal and if the bishop
moves anywhere else white actually plays
a subtle move Bishop of seven first and
there is no way to prevent Checkmate on
the next move shout out to everybody
watching this video thank you for tuning
in and enjoying our breakdown of under
promotion and we'll see you on chess.com
thank you
my name is Ethan Curry
you know we all have nicknames
um Chicago is naturally where I'm born
and raised so that's how I got the name
I guess they call me the muscle I'm the
one with the passion I'm always looking
for a good fight you know evidently they
don't make a difference man that's
Checkmate coming up they don't matter
what we're trying to do is to let them
know hey we're playing down here in
Houston Texas
and if you come down here have stepping
trust me we're going to beat you you
better bring your game
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to the coverage of the
final round of noise chess and whilst we
are waiting to grab Hikaru Nakamura and
interview him here in the studio he's
with TV2 first there were there was a
lot of excitement there in some of the
games we had an Armageddon with Magnus
we also saw ariantari defeat alireza
faruja in very spectacular way at the
end yeah it was a great day here for
Hikaru Nakamura but also for Aryan tari
getting his first win of the tournament
getting the only win by a Norwegian
player in the classical portion of the
event here uh in Stavanger and let's
just show the closing stages of that
game we earlier talked about how he had
a dominating advantage and he finished
it off actually in style ending in a
nice checkmating pattern so let's jump
in and show the closing stages there uh
this one finished as Hikaru was putting
the finishing touches polishing off his
victory and it was this position it
looks a bit chaotic but with this White
Knight on C8 tarry was very agile here
with his Maneuvers and found this nice
killer blow Knight to A7 actually the
only directly winning move in the
position clearing the square for The
Rook to deliver a check on C8 and it
turns out Black's blockade of this past
Pawn is insufficient we saw the black
Rook capture this Pawn but white simply
won a piece with a check taking this
bishop off the board and just a few
moves later we saw tarry chase the black
king into a corner first he started with
a knight check then another Rook check
Rook takes pawn and now he closed the
cage by advancing the white King Ford
the white king stepped forward
supporting a pawn push and here farouza
resigned after a check from the white
Pawn on H4 and after King H5 Rook to F6
Beautiful Finish from tari for example
Pawn to B4 would now be met by rooked F5
giving up the Rook trapping this black
king because it is now on an exposed
diagonal Beautiful checkmating Finish
there and congratulations to Ariana for
finishing on a high
congratulations to uh Aryan and uh well
we are still awaiting one final
Armageddon game between Anish giri and
Shakura mamajarov
we do have our Norway champion and what
was quite nice was that when Hikaru and
Fabiana caruana left the playing Hall
there was this huge round of applause
from The Spectators and we got a big
chair it's that's something special well
I think we have to say that both players
deserve it regardless the result because
both played showed an incredible
performance and we can say that I
believe that I I would say that Fabiano
played better chess but Nakamura was
a better sport character because to win
a last round like this to be able to
prepare to be able to stream every day
right to give commentaries during the
game all the time to be such a
determined personality the way he is
and in the last years he became a very
mixed personality but from professional
to go streaming feeling that he has to
give so much to the audience and to the
chess Enthusiast this means that and in
the last round who can win in a last
round against anybody but against
Fabiano who is in one of his best shape
he had in this tournament I mean that is
something we have to say fantastic yes
and
these guys are getting ready to play an
Armageddon oh they're getting ready to
analyze their classical game and if
she's making the psychological attack
yeah nice friendly atmosphere in the
closing game of Norway chess 2023 it
will be Geary against mamajarov uh in
this Armageddon the handshake and okay
serious faces are on it's back to the
business and it's the Roy Lopez the
Spanish opening and a repeat of the
classical encounter I think this also
means possibly that the players got
tired and they didn't want to prepare
longer more he said okay I do this and
if nothing goes wrong so badly I just
repeat it
he had this position earlier again Deja
Vu and uh in this position earlier today
and he retreated the White Queen to
protect a pawn and he's doing the same
again one of them thinks that they can
improve it has to be anishikiri surely
he's the one who needs to win in
Armageddon
okay route to D1 sliding across well
there's an improvement because
in the original game in the classical
that it was the queen that retreated
down to D1 well probably this was the
other move which Anish was thinking
about and he was hesitating which one to
move and said okay Queen D1 in the next
game Rook D1
and we've talked about the role of
seconds uh maybe he gave a quick phone
call to Owen Lammy asking what you
should do and Judith something you
talked about earlier the White Queen now
I told you that the queen could be on F4
or G3 so maybe it will touching uh it
will be touching both squares
and after Queen
G3 Bishop F4 making space for the bishop
it's beautiful for white now big attack
on this backward deep on mamajarov needs
to strike out before this bishop lands
and hits this Pawn on D6
I just don't like the Knight on A6 sorry
this Knight is rather offside especially
if Mama jar is going to open up the king
side which he aims to do by throwing his
F Pawn forward he just wants to
complicate the matter very logical move
but is it quick enough that's the
question
Plex King looks slightly exposed over
there no knights around no Defenders
how to continue to uh
Pawn hunting we like that he's going for
the D6 Pawn
and now how's black going to defense I
don't know I would have loved to see
that G5 fire on the board but instead a
bunch of Trades manager just needs to
draw remember to clinch this Armageddon
and which way to recapture now with the
Rook Queen
with the Rook of course of course white
isn't a must-win situation and uh White
has an easy target the pawn on e4
Yep this black pawn in the center is
doomed long term it's isolated it's
likely to be surrounded and there we go
after a bishop for nitrate slightly
surprising to me because black snake was
offside uh this is the idea he's hitting
he wants to get a pawn
it's worth it if you can win material
yeah
and okay that pawn defended
actually the E4 Pawn could have been
taken yeah most likely due to pins along
the e-file uh White could have got away
there with taking the E4 Pawn but Anish
just wants to keep things simple just
creating some squares for the white king
and now the BlackRock
re-centralizes Itself by stepping back
first of all
even if Rooks and queens disappear from
this board it looks like white has great
chances uh that black Bishop not too
impressive
what do we think is Anisha gonna take
this game
one move earlier if he would have asked
me I would say yes now I think H3
somehow is little slow
yeah H3 very slow and that's definitely
a blitz rapid type of move well uh yeah
I understand that Anish wanted to gain
time and H3 is always good but maybe not
good enough
and now it's not so easy for white to go
after this Pawn instead a niche okay
steps back he's going to blockade
Black's isolated Pawn in the center by
planting his Knight on the beautiful
outpost on E3 where it will never ever
be challenged
excellent strategy I have to say and
okay the Rooks do leave the board but uh
there you go the Knight is a beautiful
booklet blockader and there it is and I
was wondering about this you know would
there be a trade of absolutely
everything and then you'd leave a knight
against Bishop
yeah that's cynical but it could be
effective queen of night as well the
combo against Queen and Bishop do tend
to at least be easier to play with and
Black's Bishop will be stuck behind its
pawns for a long long time so trading
Rooks reluctance here for mamajara but
he might have to lest he seed the defile
want to go for okay roxar off the board
white tonight temporarily offside but
black has some issues with this King so
you can't venture too far with the black
queen well I wonder how white really
going to be winning if Black Goes H6
then B5 A4 let's say he stabilizes his
spawn structure I understand that the
Knight on E3 is extremely well placed
and it's blockading the E3 but to move
forward it will be not easy at all yeah
but how does black immediately deal with
his King okay we get an answer now any
Queen check okay which has just happened
will be met by a block from the black
Bishop I guess or the black king can
poke its head out
oh I just fear yeah queen of Bishop
versus queen of knights like you say
Jude it might be hard to make progress
but it's got to watch out for all those
folks for the rest of time I'm surprised
with King King G8 I was expecting
definitely to be played H6 and King H7
the bishop G6 would have been hanging so
some issues that's a different story
because once Knight C4 E5 can show up oh
the knight's coming in yeah watch out on
the dark squares that's why the bishop
here is
not the best piece simply
nice idea by Anish yeah
okay Point A4 on the board another job
just doesn't want to drop any pawns but
look at the evaluation by its level
material yet the computer thinks that
white is winning
surely based on an attack against the
black king no Anish goes Pawn hunting oh
[Laughter]
introduce his Knight but not absolutely
not material is the key points greed is
good
and in the meantime
we are going to continue with this
yep I have some good news very good news
here in the studio we are about to be
joined by a very special guest meanwhile
Anish has gonna put up in this
Armageddon game and he looks in full
control black is really stuck here while
white continues to advance his Queen
side majority
looks like and he should convert this
also a four and a half minute time
Advantage not much hope for Shaq
indeed and there you can see the bar
going all the way over to Whiteside good
news for Anish Gary's fans who well
we'll see Anish probably pick up one and
a half points but as David mentioned it
is good news for us here in the studio
as we are joined by Norway chess winner
2023 Hikaru Nakamura and wow how are you
feeling after such an epic final round
game
from the start so it wasn't super
nerve-wracking except for a couple of
couple of moments in the game but
overall I mean it was just very very uh
I don't want to say easy but it was
definitely in my control the whole way
and uh it was just quite nice that
Fabiano made a blunder and um I found
some good moves and it worked out and uh
you you mentioned in your confessional
the reason why you chose the fried liver
attack
about how it was kind of almost like a
tribute to your
second Chris Littlejohn and how they had
he'd helped you prepare this in 2009
yeah just to get those good memories
going or what did you kind of detect
something in Fabiano's kind of play well
I mean I think the main thing is is that
um when I play this opening in a muscle
in situation there are a lot of
variations which didn't occur in the
game today which can be extremely sharp
where it's almost like you just have to
play on your own and just just hope that
you can remember like 30 moves I don't I
don't need to say what the variations
are David obviously knows
um but but basically because it was must
win I didn't mind going for that and
then Fabiano played this Knight F4 which
did not completely surprise me
um but as I said in my notes for the
game the one thing that I remembered
very clearly was that in all the
variations was C5
um well not all of them but the
variations with C5 that you're supposed
to go Bishop A3 and then 94 specifically
because 94 Bishop Buffet Bishop A3
allows F5
um and so I remember that and then of
course I was still my preparation of
Fabiano played plates played this uh
play this F5 move which definitely
surprised me it was not what I was
expecting um but I think the main point
and we didn't talk much after the game
but I think I think main point is if the
rook's on A1 like you just randomly I
know put the Rook on A1 and play H3 for
example
um and so yeah in this position instead
of Rook C1
yeah like say H3 F5
um Knight takes C5 I think there there's
some there's something with like Queen
A5 I think
um maybe I'm wrong about this but I
think there's something like Queen A5
here and it's different Maybe I'm Wrong
maybe this is bad too but I just
remember there's something something
with this where whereas in the game if
we get to this position after work c105
Knights five Queen A5
um that I think Knight G5 is just just
probably winning there and I think this
is what Fabiano missed I think he missed
that Knight G5 is just extremely strong
and uh yeah well we can see from the bar
that's just game over and and after that
it was just a big big struggle and I I
don't think Fabiano really had great
chances anywhere I mean he was trying to
put up a good defense but it was just
very unpleasant the whole way so that's
it's what it is and then yeah as far as
the um preparation goes I mean besides
just just picking it I mean there
there's someone else I work with also
there's a German Grand Master and he had
mentioned something along these lines to
me about this bishop D3 move a couple
months ago and it was funny because he
wasn't even aware that I'd played this
in 2009 and I mean I'm getting to the
point now where they're games that I've
played that people just forget that I
played things it's like I remember there
was an Olympiad where Wesley and I were
teammates I forget which one it was
maybe 2016-2018 and um and I played the
Queens game accepted against van Whaley
and and after the game we were having
our team meeting Wes was like oh you
played the Queen's game of accepted
because Wesley had not seen that I
played about six or seven years earlier
and it's getting to the point where
they're all these different things that
I that I've played in another lifetime
ago and and sometimes it's fun to bring
them back and I think people just forget
that that sometimes I played I think
Fabiano probably also was completely
unaware because in 2009 uh he was
playing for Italy so I think he probably
just wasn't aware of that game
altogether and um it's just fun to
sometimes pull these old old games out
especially or these old variations out
because
um that game specifically was very uh
Monumental I think it was helpful in
terms of my career winning a second us
Championship but also I think winning
that U.S Championship is certainly I
think led to a lot of the great things
that happened in St Louis down the road
as well for the chest community and I
think you know it's just great that I
could win with this bishop D3 idea again
nice touch and uh
what do you think were the kind of
crucial elements to your success here
I think the bottom line is the fact that
there's no pressure on me versus all the
other players where there's a massive
amount of pressure I mean I think for
Fabiano the the idea of finishing second
here
um or finishing this tournament is that
being second in the world could mean a
lot in terms of qualifying for the
candidates uh additionally I mean I
think there may be our feet a circuit
tour points all these other things that
just don't I just don't even think about
them I mean if I have a chance to
qualify I'll I'll try but it's really
just not on my radar whatsoever and so I
think the fact that everybody else has
this massive pressure it makes it a lot
harder for them whereas for me I mean if
I do something stupid and lose I I can
always just go back to streaming so it's
a win-win
and if you do find yourself
number two in the world
yeah qualifying to the next stage it's
just you'll deal with that when it comes
to it yeah I mean if it happens it
happens I mean I don't even know the
regulations because I think something
like you have to play Four tournaments
or something like that I think I've
played two so far this year if I'm not
mistaken again I don't know what the
situation is with the American Cup you
know if it happens it happens if it
doesn't it doesn't doesn't change my
life um all that much um you just keep
doing I just keep doing what I'm doing
and uh how do you find the energy to not
only play chess which is also which is
quite hardcore but also stream let's go
on YouTube do your videos and play
entitled Tuesday as well well I like
like I said
um and I've said it before but I think
um you know I do consider myself a
streamer first all this other stuff I
consider it's something that I've been
doing non-stop for the last three years
pretty much
um and playing chess is rather rather
strange it's not something I've been
doing for for the last three years so
um you know I think mainly it's just my
enthusiasm for chess I've always had it
and I think sir certainly for me because
I'm not playing that many classical
games it's it's actually quite exciting
to see these positions in these various
openings on the board whereas you know
if I was playing in the grand chess tour
and all these other events I probably
would have seen like 20 berlens over the
last month and a half and I'd be sick of
Chess so it helps a lot that um that I'm
able to do all these different things
several times when you went into
confessional Booth you started out that
well I'm bored what does that mean in
that situation well I think any time the
anytime that you're able to Blitz at 20
moves and your opponent goes into a deep
thing and this happens fairly frequently
including a game against David
um or actually I think David used about
an hour 50 minutes for 20 moves but he
was able to Blitz out all the correct
moves and draw the game that that
grunfelt
um I remember but but I think yeah so
it's like when you're in your prep and
you're just sitting there waiting for
your opponent to move you don't really
know what to do because on the one hand
like you're waiting for opponent to play
the move that you expect but on the
other hand when they play a different
move it's very difficult because you're
sort of zoned out it's just you're
playing all these moves by by memory
um and it's just that's probably why I
went into the confessional Booth like
two I think I went two times in the
first like 20 or 25 minutes um because
yeah I'm just waiting for a move from
Fabiano and then fortunately when he
deviated it was just a it was a bad move
but it's it's boring I'm used to talking
and doing things all the time then I
have to sit there for like 20 minutes
waiting for a move you see going to the
confessional boost it also a stress
relief time for you there well I mean I
don't think it's about stress of relief
I don't really feel any stress or
pressure at all I think it's more that
for me looking at the bigger picture
it's something that is beneficial for
the audience I think you know once again
when you look at the games they're
really only two ways that someone who's
casual player can understand either
that's through the live commentary or
that's through the evaluation bar and
and the thing is you know when you hear
it from the players the players are not
computers as we see with all these
double question mark moves in every
single game pretty much when you hear
what the players are saying you get
their true honest opinion of how they
feel and I think certainly that's
something that has been lost with the
engine because what people say both you
know before the game after the game it's
always sort of affected by what the
computers say about the various uh
critical moments during the game and so
I just think it's beneficial and I just
that's the main reason I do it actually
is nothing to do with like relieving
stress or anything like that I just do
it because I think it's good for the
fans is it also funny for you that
you're judging practically all the games
you're giving your opinion several times
during the game and after that looking
back whether you were right in
evaluation and seeing your game and
others as well well I think actually
I've been pretty right I mean there's a
one round specifically the one where
Fabiana beat Ali Reservoir I think I
said exactly what happened in the game
where it's like you know I think if
Bobby can get the king to F7 he's just
gonna win and that's exactly what
happened
um I mean I think in general most of us
are gonna have pretty similar viewpoints
but again as far as my own games uh I
think my general General judgment was
pretty good and I was pretty close to
being accurate not not always in terms
of like what the evaluation 100 was but
where the critical moments were and I
think certainly even when I stream you
see that too where I can sort of sense
what the critical moments are and that's
like probably the most most important
thing in chess um whether it's in Blitz
whether it's in classical and I I mean I
think everybody enjoyed it so uh it's
all good yeah it was clear that you
understood what's going on not only in
your game but other games also but does
this also give you self-confidence day
by day
um I don't know about self-confidence I
think it's more that um I just try to
show up and play good chess and you know
I think the fact that I am enjoying the
games from the start makes the the
biggest difference versus I think a lot
of the other players where they feel
like it's a job they've been studying
over and over for weeks on and now with
with all these other other events going
on
um and I think yeah that's that's the
thing is that for me I when I just play
like a silly and even I'm just excited
to play it because I'm not going to have
another opportunity for a couple of
months to play classical chess so I just
enjoy it and I think for me that
actually is what makes it so so
enjoyable and leads to all the Good
Vibes and everything else that that go
along with that but do you enjoy the
whole process because of course it's not
just about playing games it's also
preparing it's also about keeping fit
and the whole shebang yeah I mean I I do
what I I can I mean like last night I
was already studying for for the game
today
um I was studying a lot harder I would
say for this last round game than some
of the other games for sure
um yeah it's a process but at the end of
the day
um the preparation seems to be good
enough and I seem to be playing well if
I survive the opening phase of the game
and uh
yeah I mean I I said it in the before
the tournament began that um that like
sooner or later I expect to have a bad
result in classical but for whatever
reason I think I'm playing Better In
classical than I am playing in Blitz
rapid and probably the last six months
um so that's I just I enjoy all of it
and I'm sure when I have a bad result
we'll see if I feel the same way but so
far whatever I'm doing seems to be
working
sadly and uh I also had a question about
Norway in general about Stavanger what
makes uh Norway chess so special
well I think in terms of organization
it's the best organized tournament in
the world I think the conditions are
really Second To None
um the organizers do all they can they
have these nice cars that they provide
so you can go wherever you want around
the city
um you know it's very Scenic with the
lake lake here
um and people are just very friendly in
general you know I think um it's it's
been it's been quite kind of wild
because coming here to Norway you know I
came a few days early for for the chess
Champions Tour event before this and you
know I go to the supermarket and I'm
just figuring well I'm in Norway it's
not that big of a deal because I've been
here before but this time around I mean
it seems like everybody recognizes me no
matter where I go and I think you know
it's it's really great to see what
Magnus has done for just what the
organizers have done here here locally
to to make this tournament so big I
think it's certainly an event that
everybody follows on I've always had a
great time here and uh to finally when
it makes it extra extra special this
time around so it's it's all all amazing
I can tell you you have a lot of fans
who watch your streams here in Norway I
do what I can I've spoken to a lot of
people on the plane then they say oh we
watch Hickory streams so you are growing
the game for sure thank you appreciate
it on that note Hikaru do you have any
words of advice for any aspiring
streamers either at home or maybe in the
studio just asking for a friend you know
I think if there's one thing that I
would say
um you you have to realize the viewers
there there is a certain IQ and I know a
lot of people assume that it's it's very
generic you just you show up you do
these things but I think certainly uh
first and foremost you have to enjoy
what you're doing I think if you if you
have a passion or you enjoy whatever
game it is even if it's not chess but
like anything really the viewers will
see that and they'll understand that and
if you're being very fake I think they
actually see through that so the main
thing is just to have a have a passion
for what you're doing and really really
enjoy it that is probably the single
biggest piece of advice that I would
give is just enjoy it and have fun with
the community that you're trying to
build
and I also have some questions from chat
asking will you play in the World Cup oh
no no I'm not I'm not playing there I've
I have other summer plans already so I'm
not gonna be playing the world oh are
you gonna Enlighten us as to these chess
plans well first of all I have to go
stream and then I'll then I'll then I'll
then I'll figure it all out but um I I
have stuff coming up oh okay and do you
have any educational things on the
horizon like Fabiano mentioned he had a
chessable course
all right yeah I mean at some point I'm
supposed to do a trustable course but
chess.com hasn't hasn't like reached out
to me about that yet so I don't even
know what the deal is with that I I I
think you know for me as a streamer the
biggest thing is I just make sure that I
show up and I do what I'm supposed to do
you know I show up and I stream and
that's really all that I worry about
even with this tournament before I came
here I didn't I didn't know what the
time control was I knew what the general
schedule was with the rounds and
everything but I didn't know the time
control I didn't know you know the
Armageddon format any of this stuff it's
just I just made sure to show up that's
that's really where my my head is at
these days
and you didn't know the rule that you
didn't need to notate no I didn't know
that either yeah because my game against
was pretty messy I think both of us were
notating when apparently we didn't have
to I mean I could have sworn though when
when fide added the increment many many
years ago I thought it was just
automatic you have to record no matter
what and so it's a little bit confusing
but I guess you live and you learn the
rules change over time I want to ask one
more thing you're the person who is
changing the chess Community quite a bit
with your stream how do you visualize
let's say the chess community and the
world in five years well I mean it's
it's very it's very hard to to tell
where things are going I think right now
we have a lot of tournaments all the top
players are very competitive they're
playing almost year round so I think for
a financial standpoint that's very good
uh will there continue to be more
tournaments it's hard hard to tell I
think actually at the moment and
personally I think they're probably a
few too many actually so
um we'll see what happens with that but
I think chess is only going to continue
to remain popular I think between myself
Magnus and others
um you know I think people really enjoy
watching chess and I I don't think
that's going to change I'm really
excited to see what happens with the
Juniors you know I think goo cache for
example I think finishes third if I'm
not mistaken um you know a very very
impressive event here and I think I
think maybe we'll see we'll see someone
finally dethroned Vichy after God knows
how many years uh as India is number one
but I think the future is very bright
with all these Juniors who are who are
up and coming and what about the time
control do you think it's going to lead
to a shorter time control more popular
or we stick to classical
um I mean I thought this time control
was very good
um I think around where we're at two
hours roughly for the whole game or
maybe a little bit less makes make sense
I don't think I mean the notion of say
the old controls 40 and 2 21 uh and then
Sunday 30 or something along those lines
even with increment I think that's
probably too much time at this point
um so I think we're gonna see around
what we're at or maybe a little bit
lower but I don't I don't think we're
going to see longer time controls I just
think for for the fans it's not it's not
great and certainly at the end of the
day you know even for me as someone who
spent my life playing chess I don't
actually watch games for seven hours I
can't do it I can spend maybe 30 minutes
one hour doing it
um and so to think that the Casual fan
which really is the target audience will
spend seven hours it's just not
realistic and so I think games that go
about maybe two two to two to four hours
around what these games were is probably
the The Sweet Spot and we actually have
a question from chat from Krista May
rakoff who says uh what did you say to
Fabi right after he resigned because
obviously it was a heartbreaking end to
his tournament yeah I mean we were we
were just discussing the game I was
basically talking about the whole 94
Bishop A3 and you know it's it's all
it's always terrible when that happens
like I had a game I think against Wesley
some years back in St Louis in a Catalan
where basically I confused an order I
played played the wrong sequence versus
the exact setup he did whereas if I'd
done it the other way versus a different
set of it would have been fine
um so we were just discussing the the
whole situation uh with this bishop a394
and then this Knight takes C5
um that's that's all we're talking about
so it was just very chess specific okay
and uh I have to say congratulations
once again for becoming Norway Charles
Champion 2023 and also for entertaining
us all with not only your confessions
but your magnificent chess as well and
uh well amazing amazing amazing
performance and well done and thank you
very much for joining us in the studio
and sharing and sharing with us your
thoughts thank you so much it was great
being here congratulations thank you
oh
and we're lucky to have the thoughts of
Hikari I mean such a magnificent winner
very worthy winner at the end you know
didn't lose a single classical game
played a perfect uh final round game and
there we can see the final standing and
ikikara Nakamura with 16 and a half
points out of 27 wins 750
000 krona which translates to 75 000
sneaking past Fabiana caruana who
finishes in second place with 16 points
out of 27 and 17 year old gukash had the
tournament of his life as he finished in
third place with 14 and a half points
out of 27 and nishikiri and Wesley so in
a fourth and fifth and what an
incredible nine days it's been
wow yeah
well we had an amazing classical games
but we have to point out that In
classical games there were not so many
decisive games before the round it was
equally seven white seven black Victory
and well this today we had two games of
classical game which decided so it was
very interesting we did not feel that
there is so little decisive games
because we had the Armageddon which kept
us entertained and it was a very rough
tournament I think for the players you
could see that they got tired and and
and what a turnover what happened in the
last game I mean that was amazing
certainly was and David were you
entertained of course Ivanka it's been a
pleasure to accommodate first of all
with the two of you Ivanka Judith thank
you
um I think the blitz tournament set the
tone for this event it was fast it was
Furious already lots of upsets uh before
the classical chess started and just uh
the way it was unpredictable the way the
players were entertaining us with these
crazy openings we saw everything we saw
the king's Gambit we saw the fried liver
attack just from Hikaru alone and uh
yeah as you situated the tournament had
it all even if the classical uh
sometimes wasn't the most exciting the
Armageddon really topped it off so the
format here at norwichs it really uh
yeah fulfilled all expectations and more
absolutely it was very special full of
action and talking about action there is
still action to come because on Monday
we have the Champions chess tour
play-ins and uh guess who is playing
Magnus Carlson he will be trying his
luck against all the title Grand Masters
in the world as they can all enter the
players so we'll see what happens there
it's gonna be a lot of fun and as the
curtain falls on the 11th edition of
Norway chess 2023 we're gonna bid
farewell to all those intense chess
battles all those fantastic moments
Judith David it's been an absolute
privilege to be sitting here
commentating alongside two legends of
the game and I'd also like to thank the
crew
and so many more names you've all been
awesome thank you very much and last but
not least I'd like to thank everyone at
home for watching in being part of this
incredible event every step of the way
so until the next time goodbye
foreign
[Music]